Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. With Amex Platinum, you have access to over 1,400 airport lounges worldwide. So your experience before takeoff is a taste of what's to come. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Conditions apply.
感谢您收听《历史就是如此》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 restishistory.com 加入俱乐部。没错，就是 restishistory.com。持有美国运通白金卡，您即可在全球 1,400 多个机场贵宾室享受礼遇。让您在起飞前的体验，成为未来美好旅程的预演。这就是美国运通的强大后盾。受相关条款约束。
This episode is brought to you by Peloton. Break through the busiest time of year with the brand new Peloton cross-training Tread Plus, powered by Peloton IQ. With real-time guidance and endless ways to move, you can personalize your workouts and train with confidence, helping you reach your goals in less time. Let yourself run, lift, sculpt, push, and go.
本期节目由 Peloton 赞助播出。在一年中最忙碌的时刻，让全新的 Peloton 交叉训练跑步机 Tread Plus 助您突破自我，它由 Peloton IQ 提供支持。通过实时指导和多种运动方式，您可以个性化定制锻炼计划，自信地进行训练，从而在更短的时间内实现目标。尽情奔跑、举重、塑形、冲刺，动起来吧。
Explore the new Peloton Cross Training Tread Plus at OnePeloton.com. Is it the matcha, or am I this energized from scoring three Sephora holiday gift sets. Definitely the sets. Full size and minis bundled together. What a steal. And that packaging is so cute. It practically wraps itself. And I know I should be giving them away, but I'm keeping the Summer Fridays and Rare Beauty by Selena Gomez. I don't blame you. The best holiday beauty sets are only at Sephora. Gift sets from Summer Fridays, Rare Beauty, way and more are going fast. Get full-sized favorites and must-have minis bundled for more value.
请访问 OnePeloton.com 探索全新的 Peloton 交叉训练跑步机 Tread Plus。是因为抹茶，还是因为我抢到了三套丝芙兰节日礼盒而如此兴奋？肯定是礼盒的原因。正装和迷你装组合在一起，简直太划算了。而且包装也太可爱了，几乎都不用再包装了。我知道我应该把它们送人，但我打算留下 Summer Fridays 和 Rare Beauty by Selena Gomez 的套装。我不怪你。最好的节日美妆礼盒只在丝芙兰。来自 Summer Fridays、Rare Beauty、Ouai 等品牌的礼盒正在热销中。购买正装挚爱产品与必备迷你装的组合，享受更多超值优惠。
Shop before they're gone. In store online at Sephora.ca. This episode is sponsored by Hive. History has always been a story of power, who seeks it, who seizes it, and how easily it can all slip away. The Caesars, the Caliphs, the Tsars, they conquered vast swaths of the world, they proclaimed themselves, the favourites of the gods, and yet their empires crumbled away. It is easier to conquer than it is to control. Hive takes a different approach. It puts power where it belongs in your hands. They started with smart thermostats and they've now gone much further.
趁售罄前快去选购吧。请前往丝芙兰门店或访问 Sephora.ca。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。历史始终是一个关于权力的故事：谁在寻求权力，谁在攫取权力，以及权力又是如何轻易地溜走。凯撒、哈里发、沙皇，他们征服了广袤的土地，自诩为神的宠儿，然而他们的帝国最终还是土崩瓦解。征服容易，治理难。Hive 采取了不同的方式。它将权力归还给它应在的地方——您的手中。他们从智能恒温器起步，如今已走得更远。
Solar panels, heat pumps, EV chargers all working together so that you can power your home in your own way. That's genuine empowerment. Checking your phone. seeing the heating's on, the car's charging, and the sun is quietly earning its keep on the roof. Caesar never had to charge his chariots, but I'm sure he would have admired the efficiency. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, hive compatible with selected technology. Of Queen Mary this truly may be affirmed and left in story for a perpetual memorial or epitaph for all kings and queens that shall succeed her, to be noted, that before her never was read in story of any king or queen of England, under whom, in time of peace, by hanging, beheading, burning and prisoning, so much Christian blood.
太阳能电池板、热泵、电动汽车充电桩，所有设备协同工作，让您能以自己的方式为家庭供电。这才是真正的赋能。查看手机，看到暖气已开启，汽车正在充电，屋顶上的太阳能板正在静静地为您创造价值。凯撒从未需要给他的战车充电，但我相信他一定会钦佩这种效率。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定，Hive 与特定技术兼容。关于玛丽女王，这确实可以得到证实，并作为对她之后所有国王和女王的永久纪念或墓志铭留在史册中：值得注意的是，在史书中从未读到过，在英国历史上，有哪位国王或女王在位期间，在和平时期，通过绞刑、斩首、火刑和监禁，造成了如此多的基督徒流血。
So many Englishmen's lives were spilled within this realm as under the said Queen Mary for the space of four years was to be seen. And I beseech the Lord never may be seen hereafter. So that was the Tudor No. 1 bestseller. The thrillingly titled Acts and Monuments of these latter and perilous days touching matters of the church. And it was by an unusually forensic. and judicious historian, John Fox, a man of Lincolnshire, hence the accent, and that book
在这个王国里，有如此多英国人的生命被夺走，正如在上述玛丽女王统治的四年间所见。我祈求上帝，愿此后永远不再见到这样的景象。这就是都铎王朝的第一畅销书。那本标题惊心动魄的《这些危险的末世中关于教会事务的法案与纪念碑》。它的作者是一位不同寻常的、严谨的历史学家——约翰·福克斯，一位林肯郡人，所以他有那种口音，而那本书
went down in English history as Fox's Book of Martyrs, one of the foundational texts. You might argue of English national identity. It was published in 1563, five years after the death of the character he's talking about Mary Tudor. And Tom, in that passage, John Fox is describing the depredations, crimes and horrors of her reign. A rain so drenched in blood that to this day, and I remember this when we did it at school when I was about 10, she is still known as Bloody Mary. And he's not just talking about Mary, is he? He's talking about the subject of our series, which is Elizabeth, because Elizabeth is the yin to Mary's yang. Well, or is she, or do they actually have more in common perhaps than is conventionally assumed?
在英国历史上被称为《福克斯殉道者名录》，你可以说它是英国民族认同的奠基文本之一。它出版于 1563 年，即他所谈论的人物玛丽·都铎去世五年后。汤姆，在那段文字中，约翰·福克斯描述了她统治时期的掠夺、罪行和恐怖。那是一个血流成河的时代，以至于直到今天——我记得我大约 10 岁在学校学到这段历史时——她仍然被称为“血腥玛丽”。他不仅仅是在谈论玛丽，对吧？他是在谈论我们这个系列的主题，也就是伊丽莎白，因为伊丽莎白是玛丽的对立面。嗯，或者说她是吗？还是说她们实际上比传统认为的更有共同点？
we will be finding out in this episode. But specifically, that passage comes in an entire segment that is focused on Elizabeth and what Fox sees as the miracle that enables Elizabeth to survive the reign of Bloody Mary, her half-sister. And Fox thinks that obviously Elizabeth is absolutely brilliant because Fox is writing as a Protestant, Elizabeth is a Protestant. But just as he thinks Elizabeth is brilliant. He thinks Mary is an absolute shocker, the worst ruler ever on the English throne. So he casts Mary as this terrifying papist tyrant and Elizabeth as a Protestant deliverer. He says that Mary was inflamed with zeal, not for God, but for idolatry, whereas Elizabeth is a restorer of the gospel. He describes how Mary-filled England.
我们将在本期节目中找出答案。但具体来说，那段文字出自一个完整的章节，该章节聚焦于伊丽莎白，以及福克斯所认为的使伊丽莎白能够在“血腥玛丽”（她的同父异母姐姐）统治下幸存下来的奇迹。福克斯认为伊丽莎白显然非常出色，因为福克斯是以新教徒的身份写作的，而伊丽莎白也是新教徒。但正如他认为伊丽莎白出色一样，他认为玛丽是一个彻头彻尾的恶棍，是英国王位上最糟糕的统治者。因此，他将玛丽描绘成一个可怕的教皇暴君，将伊丽莎白描绘成一位新教救世主。他说玛丽被狂热所煽动，不是为了上帝，而是为了偶像崇拜，而伊丽莎白则是福音的恢复者。他描述了玛丽如何让英国充满了
with smoke from the burning of God's saint, whereas Elizabeth, when she comes to the throne, is all about the advancement of learning and godliness. And he's not exaggerating the differences, is he? So just to remind people, we ended last time with the death of Edward the 6th, their brother. So he'd been an ultra-protestant, a kind of evangelical reformer.
焚烧上帝圣徒的烟雾，而伊丽莎白在登上王位后，致力于促进学习和虔诚。他并没有夸大这些差异，对吧？所以提醒一下大家，我们上次是以爱德华六世（他们的兄弟）的去世结束的。他曾是一位极端的新教徒，一种福音派改革者。
So we are in 1553. And now we are going to find out what happens. Edward wanted his Protestant relative Lady Jane Gray to succeed him. But Mary is, of course, the obvious person, more beloved of the English people. But the thing about her that everybody knows, the thing that Fox knew, that we learn in schools, that everybody knew at the time, was that her defining characteristic was her loyalty to the faith of her mother, Catherine of Arrigan. That is to say she is a Catholic. Are people using the words Catholic and Protestant by this time?
所以我们现在处于 1553 年。现在我们要看看接下来发生了什么。爱德华希望他的新教亲戚简·格雷夫人继位。但玛丽当然是显而易见的人选，更受英国人民的爱戴。但关于她，每个人都知道的一点，福克斯知道，我们在学校学到的，当时每个人都知道的，就是她最显著的特征是她对母亲阿拉贡的凯瑟琳的信仰的忠诚。也就是说，她是一位天主教徒。当时人们在使用“天主教”和“新教”这些词吗？
Not really. It's still a little bit muddy. Again, we'll be kind of looking at that. But I think the sense of Europe being divided into kind of rival polls is starting to clarify. But Mary, remember, is of an older generation. Yeah. She's not entirely on top of that. But anyway, she sees herself as upholding the traditional faith of England.
并不完全是。情况仍然有点模糊。同样，我们会对此进行探讨。但我认为欧洲正分裂成某种对立阵营的感觉开始变得清晰起来。但请记住，玛丽属于老一辈。是的。她并没有完全掌握这一点。但无论如何，她认为自己是在维护英国的传统信仰。
and when she's interrogated by her brother's counsel in 1550 she's absolutely up front about this she says I would rather refuse the friendship of all the world than forsake any point of my faith and to that end she had defied her father Henry the 8th and she defies her brother Edward the 6th she attends mass daily she refuses to accept the very radical Protestant reforms that her brother is pushing forward. And remember, there is a huge age difference. Edward, by 1553, when he dies, he's still just a teenager and a very priggish teenager and very vehemently Protestant.
当她在 1550 年受到她兄弟的议会质询时，她非常坦率地表示：我宁愿拒绝全世界的友谊，也不愿放弃我信仰的任何一点。为此，她违抗了她的父亲亨利八世，也违抗了她的兄弟爱德华六世。她每天参加弥撒，拒绝接受她兄弟正在推行的激进新教改革。请记住，她们之间有巨大的年龄差距。到 1553 年爱德华去世时，他仍然只是一个十几岁的少年，一个非常迂腐的少年，而且是极其坚定的新教徒。
And I think that he views his elder sister rather in the way that a student coming back from his first term at university might view, you know, a middle-aged turf or someone like that. She's in her late 30s. She's 37 in 1553. Yes. And I think Edward just feels, you know, she's got these very antiquated, unacceptable, very cancelable views. Her religious views are problematic, right? Yes. Elizabeth is different because Elizabeth, unlike Mary, had done well under her brother's rule. So she also, like Mary, has inherited a faith from her mother. Elizabeth's mother, of course, Anne Boleyn was an evangelical and Elizabeth has been raised in that faith. But actually, the huge influence on her, obviously is in Ambelin, because she's mother. Amblin died when Elizabeth was only three and a half. It's her stepmother, Catherine Parr, Henry VIII's last wife. And like Catherine, Elizabeth, I think, has an authentically evangelical sense of convictions, but she also quite likes a crucifix, you know, a choir,
我认为他看待他姐姐的方式，就像一个刚从大学第一学期回来的学生看待一个中年老古板那样。她已经快 40 岁了。1553 年她 37 岁。是的。我认为爱德华只是觉得，她有这些非常过时、不可接受、非常应该被“取消”的观点。她的宗教观点是有问题的，对吧？是的。伊丽莎白则不同，因为伊丽莎白与玛丽不同，她在她兄弟的统治下表现良好。所以她也像玛丽一样，从母亲那里继承了一种信仰。伊丽莎白的母亲安妮·博林当然是一位福音派信徒，伊丽莎白也是在这种信仰中长大的。但实际上，对她影响最大的人显然是安妮·博林，因为她是母亲。安妮·博林在伊丽莎白只有三岁半时就去世了。是她的继母，亨利八世的最后一任妻子凯瑟琳·帕尔。和凯瑟琳一样，我认为伊丽莎白有着真实的福音派信念，但她也相当喜欢十字架，你知道，唱诗班，
a cathedral close, all of that. The core is evangelical, Protestant, if you want to call it like that, but she's perfectly happy with, you know, a bit of traditional cladding. Yeah. And to that extent she's much less kind of obviously Protestant than Edward, who is all about, you know, if there's anything that's more than 15 years old, rip it down, whitewash it. But the one thing that Elizabeth does do to signal to her brother, her religious affiliations, and we'd mentioned this in the last episode, she very ostentatiously wears plain and sober clothes. And I think that's quite a challenge for Elizabeth, because she does love a beautiful dress. Nice dressing up. So, obvious question. Edward VI is dying. He knows he's dying.
大教堂的庭院，所有这些。核心是福音派，如果你想这么称呼它的话，但她对一些传统的装饰也完全乐于接受。是的。在这一点上，她显然比爱德华少得多地表现出新教色彩，爱德华主张如果有什么东西超过 15 年历史，就把它拆掉、刷白。但伊丽莎白确实做了一件事来向她兄弟表明她的宗教倾向，我们在上一集提到过，她非常显眼地穿着朴素庄重的衣服。我认为这对伊丽莎白来说是一个很大的挑战，因为她确实喜欢漂亮的裙子。喜欢打扮。所以，显而易见的问题。爱德华六世快要死了。他知道自己快要死了。
He regards it as his last duty on earth to ensure that England passes into the hands of somebody who will uphold what he sees as the unproblematic evangelical religion. Why does he not basically arrange the succession for his half-sister Elizabeth? Why does he turn to Lady Jane Grey instead? It's such a good question. I remember when we did our episodes on Lady Jane Grey that we discussed this question then. And I think the answer is that we've been talking about how different. Mary and Elizabeth Arbour. They also have very, very profound similarities. So both of them are the daughters of mothers who've been rejected by their father, Henry the 8th. Catherine of Aragon had
他认为确保英国传给一个能够维护他所认为的“无争议的福音派宗教”的人，是他在这世上的最后职责。为什么他基本上没有为他同父异母的姐姐伊丽莎白安排继位？为什么他转而选择了简·格雷夫人？这是一个很好的问题。我记得我们在做关于简·格雷夫人的剧集时，我们就讨论过这个问题。我认为答案是，我们一直在谈论玛丽和伊丽莎白有多么不同。她们也有非常、非常深刻的相似之处。所以她们俩都是被父亲亨利八世抛弃的母亲的女儿。阿拉贡的凯瑟琳
been packed off and Ballin had a head chopped off. Both of them had been born as princesses and lost that title under Henry the 8th and under Edward the 6th. They're called Lady rather than Princess. Yeah. And this is because both of them have been officially and legally declared bastards by Act of Parliament. So there is a sense that both of them have a kind of shared taint. And it's this that prompts Edward to decide that they should have to be removed from the succession, which Henry VIII had kind of said that, you know, they should succeed him. Edward decides he's going to overturn that and appoint his heir, as you said, their cousin, Lady Jane Gray.
被遣送走，安妮·博林被砍了头。她们俩出生时都是公主，但在亨利八世和爱德华六世统治下失去了那个头衔。她们被称为“夫人”而不是“公主”。是的。这是因为她们俩都被议会法案正式且合法地宣布为私生女。所以有一种感觉，她们俩都有某种共同的污点。正是这一点促使爱德华决定她们应该被排除在继承权之外，而亨利八世曾说过她们应该继位。爱德华决定推翻这一点，并任命他的继承人，正如你所说，是她们的表亲，简·格雷夫人。
I suppose the truth is you can't have Elizabeth and not have Mary, right? If you can legitimize Elizabeth, then why are you excluding Mary? Yeah, I think that's right. And so Edward dies on the 6th of July 1553, and Jane's father-in-law, the Duke of Northumberland, one of the Dudley families, he declares Jane Queen, but as we heard in the last episode and in the two episodes that we did years ago on Lady Jane Grey, episodes 239 and 240, for those who are interested, it all goes wrong. Elizabeth hunkers down in Hatfield, her great house in Hertfordshire, but Mary is much more
我想事实是，你不能拥有伊丽莎白而不拥有玛丽，对吧？如果你能让伊丽莎白合法化，那么你为什么要排除玛丽呢？是的，我想那是对的。所以爱德华于 1553 年 7 月 6 日去世，简的公公，诺森伯兰公爵，达德利家族成员之一，他宣布简为女王，但正如我们在上一集以及我们几年前做的关于简·格雷夫人的两集（第 239 和 240 集，感兴趣的朋友可以去听）中所听到的那样，一切都搞砸了。伊丽莎白躲在赫特福德郡的哈特菲尔德大宅里，但玛丽要
proactive. She's in East Anglia. She raises basically the kind of the English people against Lady Jane's regime. And Lady Jane ends up ruling so briefly that she will be commemorated inaccurately, actually, as the nine-day queen. And so the tutors are able to maintain their hold on the throne. Because, of course, that's what's at stake. It's a struggle not just for Mary to obtain what she sees as her birthright, but also to keep the Tudor dynastic hold on the throne. And because Elizabeth is next in line to Mary, Mary's triumph is also, in a sense, Elizabeth's. And so Elizabeth makes sure to share in it. And she actually enters London before Mary on the 29th of July. So she arrives from Hatfield and she's escorted by 2,000 horsemen. And they have spears, they have
主动得多。她在东安格利亚。她基本上发动了英国人民反对简·格雷夫人的政权。简·格雷夫人的统治时间如此短暂，以至于她实际上会被不准确地纪念为“九日女王”。因此，都铎家族得以维持对王位的控制。因为，当然，这就是利害攸关的事情。这不仅是玛丽为了获得她所认为的与生俱来的权利而进行的斗争，也是为了保持都铎王朝对王位的控制。而且因为伊丽莎白是玛丽之后的顺位继承人，玛丽的胜利在某种意义上也是伊丽莎白的胜利。所以伊丽莎白确保自己也参与其中。她实际上在 7 月 29 日比玛丽先进入伦敦。所以她从哈特菲尔德赶来，由 2,000 名骑兵护送。他们带着长矛，带着
bows, they have guns, and they're dressed in the green and white livery of the Tudors. And this is obviously a very public declaration, a reminder to people, not just that she is there, that she is a Tudor like her Victoria sister, but also that she is a heavyweight in her own right. If she can command 2,000 horsemen, then it promotes her to the people of London and the country more generally. As someone with backing, with wealth, with lands, she is a person of great substance in her own right. And to remind people, she is going to turn, she's not yet turned 20. So she is 19 and a half years old. She's still effectively a teenager. A very daunting moment, but a good example of her political skill and the kind of the cool and the steel
弓箭，带着枪，穿着都铎家族的绿白制服。这显然是一个非常公开的声明，提醒人们，不仅是她在那儿，她和她维多利亚时代的姐姐一样是都铎家族的人，而且她本身也是一个重量级人物。如果她能指挥 2,000 名骑兵，那么这就在伦敦人民和全国范围内提升了她的形象。作为一个有后盾、有财富、有土地的人，她本身就是一个非常有实力的人。提醒一下，她快要满 20 岁了。所以她 19 岁半。她实际上还是个青少年。一个非常令人生畏的时刻，但这是她政治技巧以及那种冷静和钢铁般意志的一个很好的例子
beneath the surface, right? Yeah. And of course, it's a reminder to Mary. And Elizabeth comes in from the northwest of London, rides through the city, heads out east, and Mary is approaching London from East Anglia, and the two sisters meet at Wonstead, east of London. And this is the first time that they've met for three years. And Mary welcomes Elizabeth very warmly, and we're told even to kissing all her ladies. So that's very nice. And on the 3rd of August, Mary makes her formal entry into London. and Elizabeth is riding by her side.
隐藏在表面之下，对吧？是的。当然，这也是对玛丽的一个提醒。伊丽莎白从伦敦西北部进入，骑马穿过城市，向东走，而玛丽正从东安格利亚接近伦敦，两姐妹在伦敦东部的旺斯特德会面。这是她们三年来第一次见面。玛丽非常热情地欢迎伊丽莎白，据说甚至亲吻了她所有的侍女。所以这很好。8 月 3 日，玛丽正式进入伦敦，伊丽莎白骑在她的身边。
And I think Elizabeth, who's a very shrewd observer, would have noted two things in particular about Mary's triumphant entry into the capital. The first is the crowds cheer her ecstatically. They are as enthusiastic to see a queen as they ever were to see a king. And this is a key revelation, because Mary is the first woman to be ruling
我认为伊丽莎白，作为一个非常精明的观察者，会特别注意到玛丽凯旋进入首都的两件事。第一是人群狂热地为她欢呼。他们看到女王时表现出的热情，和他们看到国王时一样。这是一个关键的启示，因为玛丽是第一位女性统治者
in her own right since Stephen and Matilda and Matilda had not her rule had not been uncontested so really Mary is the first queen regnant to rule in an uncontested way in English history
自斯蒂芬和玛蒂尔达以来，玛蒂尔达的统治并没有受到挑战，所以玛丽确实是英国历史上第一位以不受挑战的方式统治的女王。
and people salute and hail and cheer her as a monarch the irony Henry the 8th it had all been for nothing all that faffing around with wives he'd assumed I suppose after the wars of the roses understandably he had assumed
人们向她致敬、欢呼，称她为君主。讽刺的是，亨利八世所做的一切都是徒劳的。他折腾那些妻子，我想在玫瑰战争之后，可以理解的是，他曾假设
there'll probably be more civil wars, you'll need to command armies, all of that kind of business. But he was wrong because actually the affection for the dynasty is such and what people regard as the legitimate line, that Mary never really has, well, we'll come to what ructions there are later on, but she never really has that much difficulty in cementing her regime, does she?
可能会有更多的内战，你需要指挥军队，所有这些事情。但他错了，因为实际上人们对王朝的感情是如此深厚，以及人们所认为的合法血统，以至于玛丽从来没有——嗯，我们稍后会谈到有什么冲突——但她从来没有在巩固政权方面遇到太大的困难，对吧？
No, she doesn't. And I think it makes clear that there are opportunities for a queen to command the love and devotion of her subjects just as there are for a king. But having said that, I think the other thing that Elizabeth notices, as she's riding by her sister's side, is that the cheering for her as the younger and more glamorous sister is louder. And I think that is something also that she bears in mind, that if the people of London are saluting the ruling queen, she also is a very, very popular person.
不，她没有。我认为这清楚地表明，女王和国王一样，都有机会赢得臣民的爱戴和忠诚。但话虽如此，我认为伊丽莎白在骑在姐姐身边时注意到的另一件事是，作为更年轻、更迷人的妹妹，为她欢呼的声音更大。我认为这也是她铭记在心的一点，如果伦敦人民在向在位女王致敬，她也是一个非常、非常受欢迎的人。
and her reliance on the love of her subjects will be a running theme throughout the next few years and then when she becomes queen throughout her reign. How do we know that the cheers were louder for her? So that must come from witnesses at the time, but how do we know that they're not party pre? Because it's noted by people who are sympathetic to Mary and it's a cause of concern.
她对臣民之爱的依赖将成为未来几年，以及她成为女王后整个统治期间的一个贯穿主题。我们怎么知道为她欢呼的声音更大？这一定来自当时的目击者，但我们怎么知道他们不是有偏见呢？因为这被那些同情玛丽的人注意到了，这引起了担忧。
Right. Because obviously, you know, it's not the kind of thing that would make Mary feel brilliant about Elizabeth with whom she already has a very complicated relationship. Although, having said that to begin with, for the first few weeks, their relationship seems okay to reiterate the point that David Starkey make, which we quoted in the earlier episode, Mary was tenderhearted to excess when issues of principle were not involved. So, of course, the issue of principle in that comment is the sticking point. But I think even on this score, Mary is not the monstrous bigot of Fox's Book of Martyrs. Well, I'm delighted to hear this because as you know from last week's episodes, I actually have a lot of time for Queen Mary.
对。因为显然，这不是那种会让玛丽对伊丽莎白感觉良好的事情，她们之间已经有了一种非常复杂的关系。尽管话虽如此，起初的几周，她们的关系似乎还可以，重申大卫·斯塔基在之前剧集中提到的观点，当不涉及原则问题时，玛丽的内心是非常温柔的。所以，当然，那个评论中的原则问题是症结所在。但我认为即使在这一点上，玛丽也不是《福克斯殉道者名录》中那个可怕的偏执狂。嗯，我很高兴听到这个，因为正如你从上周的剧集中所知，我实际上非常欣赏玛丽女王。
I think she's a very impressive person. And actually, it's really important in this context to hammer home the point that basically it's not so simple as they're being card-carrying Catholics and card-carrying Protestants. The whole kind of religious ecosystem is in flux. To see it just as two camps is wrong, isn't it? Because actually people are trying to find their place in the new order. And it's not necessarily obvious to people what they are and how things will settle down. Yeah. And so it's perfectly possible for Mary throughout, you know, all the time that Henry VIII has been terrible to her, she continues to proclaim her admiration for him.
我认为她是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。实际上，在这种背景下，强调这一点非常重要，即基本上事情并不像“持证天主教徒”和“持证新教徒”那样简单。整个宗教生态系统都在不断变化。仅仅将其视为两个阵营是错误的，不是吗？因为实际上人们正在试图在新秩序中找到自己的位置。人们并不一定清楚自己是什么，以及事情将如何安定下来。是的。所以玛丽在整个过程中，你知道，在亨利八世对她很糟糕的所有时间里，她继续宣称对他的钦佩，这是完全可能的。
And she does so now that she's queen. Henry serves her as a role model. She allows her dead brother, Edward VI, to be buried using the Protestant funeral service. And in fact, both Henry and Edward as, well, Henry's not exactly a Protestant, but I mean, he's a kind of weird kind of Catholic who's thrown off the papal supremacy. Edward is definitely a Protestant. Both of them uphold the notion that the king should be the head of the Church of England and use that to ram through their reforms of the Church of England. Mary as a Catholic thinks that the papal supremacy should be restored and does that very quickly. But even once she's done that, she still operates on the assumption, basically, that she's the head of the Church of England. I mean, what she decides basically goes.
她现在身为女王也是如此。亨利是她的榜样。她允许她已故的兄弟爱德华六世使用新教葬礼仪式下葬。事实上，亨利和爱德华——嗯，亨利并不完全是新教徒，但我的意思是，他是一种奇怪的天主教徒，抛弃了教皇的至高无上地位。爱德华绝对是新教徒。他们俩都坚持认为国王应该是英国教会的首脑，并利用这一点来强行推行他们的英国教会改革。玛丽作为天主教徒认为应该恢复教皇的至高无上地位，并很快做到了这一点。但即使在她做完这些之后，她仍然基本上在假设她是英国教会的首脑。我的意思是，她决定的事情基本上就是定论。
So she's inherited that assumption as well, I think, from her father and her brother. But the reason that she doesn't really see any tension there is, as you said, that she doesn't really have a sense of their having been. a reformation that needs to be counted. She doesn't really think that the scale of the upheaval that England has gone through is something that has imposed a kind of binary contrast on England. So to quote Lucy Wooding in her wonderful introduction to Tudor England, which I think is the best single volume on Tudor England that there is, she writes, Mary seems to have had the firm conviction that, bar a few troublemakers, she was essentially ruling a Catholic country with the support of its people. But that's probably true, isn't it?
所以我想她也从她父亲和兄弟那里继承了这种假设。但她之所以没有真正看到任何紧张关系，正如你所说，是因为她并没有真正意识到他们经历过一场需要被清算的宗教改革。她并不认为英国所经历的动荡规模已经给英国强加了一种二元对立。所以引用露西·伍丁在她那本精彩的《都铎王朝英国导论》中的话，我认为这是关于都铎王朝英国最好的单卷本，她写道，玛丽似乎有一种坚定的信念，即除了少数捣乱分子外，她本质上是在统治一个天主教国家，并得到了人民的支持。但这可能是真的，不是吗？
I mean, in so far as most people, if you said to them, you're a Catholic Protestant, they'd look at you like, you were mad. Maybe younger people, as in people under the age of 20, will have been brought up in a more evangelical mindset. But older people, I mean, people are aware that changes have happened, and many of them will probably say, God, a lot of these changes are a bit bonkers, aren't they? I don't really understand them myself. But they don't, they don't don't think to themselves, well, we're living through the Reformation. I wonder if there'll be a counter-reformation. I mean, that's not how people think. I think that's absolutely right. So to that extent, Mary is correct that there's a kind of bit of spring cleaning that needs to be done. There's
我的意思是，如果大多数人被问到“你是天主教徒还是新教徒”，他们会像看疯子一样看着你。也许年轻人，比如 20 岁以下的人，会在更福音派的心态中长大。但年长的人，我的意思是，人们意识到变化已经发生，他们中的许多人可能会说，天哪，这些变化中有很多有点疯狂，不是吗？我自己并不真正理解它们。但他们不会想，嗯，我们正在经历宗教改革。我想知道是否会有反宗教改革。我的意思是，人们不是那样想的。我认为这绝对是对的。所以在这一点上，玛丽是对的，即需要进行一点大扫除。有
kind of damage being done. Yeah, things have gone much too far. Things have gone too far, but you just tidied up and then things will basically be as they were. Now, it has to be said, you know, we also have this idea, I think, that there's such a thing as Catholicism, which is monolithic, refusing to change. But that's not the case at all, because the Catholic world like the Protestant world in the 16th century is in a constant state of flux. There are Catholic reformers. There are people in the upper echelons of the Catholic Church who absolutely feel that reform is necessary. And Mary herself belongs to that wing of the Catholic Church. So she never goes on pilgrimage as a queen. Before she came to the throne, she had helped to translate Erasmus,
某种损害已经造成。是的，事情走得太远了。事情走得太远了，但你只需要整理一下，然后事情基本上就会恢复原样。现在，必须说，你知道，我们也有这种想法，我认为，存在一种天主教，它是单一的，拒绝改变。但事实根本不是这样，因为 16 世纪的天主教世界就像新教世界一样，处于不断的变动状态。有天主教改革者。在天主教教会的高层中，有人绝对认为改革是必要的。玛丽本人就属于天主教教会的那个派别。所以她作为女王从未去朝圣。在她登上王位之前，她曾帮助翻译伊拉斯谟的作品，
who's the great humanist scholar, who had been a kind of a coruscating critic of corruption in the Catholic Church. And she had no problem at all with using the Bible in English. She thought, you know, that was fine as well. And just to reiterate, she belongs to this generation that hasn't yet conceptualized, I think, the notion of their being Catholics and Protestants. And that's why she feels that she's not kind of instituting a counter-reformation, really. As I say, it's just a kind of process of housekeeping, of tidying things up that have been a little bit smashed up. Now, as it turns out, that's not entirely the case because, of course, what she is demanding of people who have accepted reformed religion, who are Protestants, as we might call them, she is obliging them to make a choice.
他是伟大的文艺复兴人文主义学者，曾是天主教教会腐败的尖锐批评者。她对使用英语圣经也完全没有问题。她认为，你知道，那也很好。再次重申，她属于这一代人，我认为他们还没有概念化存在天主教徒和新教徒的概念。这就是为什么她觉得她并没有真正发起一场反宗教改革。正如我所说，这只是一种家务整理的过程，整理那些被弄得有点破碎的东西。现在，事实证明，情况并非完全如此，因为当然，她对那些接受了改革宗教的人，也就是我们可能称之为新教徒的人所要求的，是强迫他们做出选择。
Because actually, papal supremacy is something that has become a massive sticking point for people like that. And the most prominent person for whom this is an issue is, of course, her sister Elizabeth. But I think it's a reflection not just on Elizabeth's character, but on the general tenor of evangelicals at this point, that Elizabeth is not prepared to be martyred. So Fox's Book of Martyrs, as its name suggests, there are lots of people who will be prepared to go to the stake. But relatively speaking, relative to the number of Protestants that they probably are in England this time, there aren't actually that many because most people are happy to do as Elizabeth does and kind of just kind of keep their head down. So Elizabeth,
因为实际上，教皇的至高无上地位已经成为像那样的人的一个巨大症结。而对此问题最突出的人当然是她的妹妹伊丽莎白。但我认为，这不仅反映了伊丽莎白的性格，也反映了当时福音派的普遍倾向，即伊丽莎白并没有准备好成为殉道者。所以《福克斯殉道者名录》，顾名思义，有很多人准备好走上火刑柱。但相对而言，相对于当时英国可能存在的新教徒数量，实际上并没有那么多，因为大多数人乐于像伊丽莎白那样，保持低调。所以伊丽莎白，
knowing, you know, she's got to prove herself to Mary. Early in September, she requests an audience with her sister. She's a great actress. She falls down on her knees, tears streaming from her cheeks, lamenting that Mary seems ill-disposed to her. And to quote, she knew of no other cause except religion. She might be excused in this because she had been brought up in the way she held and had never been taught the doctrine of the ancient religion. That's a good card to play, because Mary knows that's absolutely, you know, she knows that's true. And the real victim in all this. Yeah. So Elizabeth says, well, you know, can you send me a priest, give me books that I can read up
知道，你知道，她必须向玛丽证明自己。9 月初，她请求觐见她的姐姐。她是一位伟大的演员。她跪倒在地，泪水从脸颊流下，哀叹玛丽似乎对她怀有恶意。引用她的话，除了宗教，她不知道还有什么原因。她在这方面可能会被原谅，因为她是在她所持有的方式中长大的，从未被教导过古老宗教的教义。这是一张好牌，因为玛丽知道这绝对是，你知道，她知道这是真的。而这一切中真正的受害者。是的。所以伊丽莎白说，好吧，你知道，你能派给我一个牧师，给我一些我可以阅读的书，让我
and, you know, learn the error of my ways. And on the 8th of September, she duly attends mass with Mary at the Chapel Royal, although again, a kind of classic Elizabeth maneuver. She does try to get out of it by pulling a sickie. But Mary sends a doctor and says actually nothing fine. Yeah. So after that quite promising start, things start to get tense again, don't they? And how much of this do you think is that, I mean, it's an interesting question actually, how much have they inherited the bad blood between Catherine of Aragon and Amberlin?
你知道，学习我方式中的错误。9 月 8 日，她如期与玛丽一起在皇家礼拜堂参加了弥撒，尽管这又是一种经典的伊丽莎白式策略。她确实试图通过装病来逃避。但玛丽派了一名医生，说实际上没什么大碍。是的。所以在那个相当有希望的开始之后，事情又开始变得紧张了，不是吗？你认为这其中有多少是，我的意思是，这实际上是一个有趣的问题，她们在多大程度上继承了阿拉贡的凯瑟琳和安妮·博林之间的积怨？
So how much does, you know, obviously Mary hated Ambelin because Ambelin was horrible to her? Does she blame Elizabeth at some subconscious level, do you think? Possibly. I mean, once the kind of complications of religious divides have been removed, as we've said, Mary has been incredibly kind to Elizabeth
所以，你知道，显然玛丽讨厌安妮·博林，因为安妮·博林对她很糟糕？你认为她在某种潜意识层面上责怪伊丽莎白吗？有可能。我的意思是，一旦宗教分歧的复杂性被消除，正如我们所说，玛丽对伊丽莎白一直非常友善
and viewed her as a sister. But the moment that religion complicates the picture, then things start go tense again. And Mary in the first months of her reign is busy disassembling the Protestantism of her brother. And she knows that Elizabeth is unsympathetic to this. And so she starts to see Elizabeth again as a threat. And specifically, she begins to go on to her advisors that Elizabeth resembles Anne Boleyn. And again, to quote, as her mother had caused great trouble in the kingdom, the queen feared that Elizabeth might do the same. But important, to say, Mary's anxieties about Elizabeth are not just on the religious dimension, because
并把她视为妹妹。但当宗教使情况变得复杂时，事情又开始变得紧张了。玛丽在她统治的最初几个月里，忙于拆解她兄弟的新教。她知道伊丽莎白对此并不赞同。所以她开始再次将伊丽莎白视为威胁。具体来说，她开始向她的顾问们抱怨伊丽莎白像安妮·博林。再次引用她的话，正如她母亲在王国中引起了巨大的麻烦一样，女王担心伊丽莎白可能会做同样的事情。但重要的是要说，玛丽对伊丽莎白的焦虑不仅是在宗教层面，因为
there is also a further one, which is that of foreign policy. And Mary is worried that Elizabeth might imitate Anne Berlin in being a French partisan. Well, that's a massive issue throughout all this period, isn't it? That's often forgotten in the sort of popular literature or the popular understanding of it. The cleavages in British politics are not just about religion, but they're also about, you know, there are two big powers in Europe and which one are you going to ally yourself with? Berlin, of course, had come from France. Her father had been a diplomat in France. And Elizabeth is perceived as being a francophile rather than a kind of Hispanophile. Yeah, and this is a problem
还有一个层面，那就是外交政策。玛丽担心伊丽莎白可能会模仿安妮·博林，成为法国的党派。嗯，这是整个时期的一个巨大问题，不是吗？这在某种流行文学或流行理解中经常被遗忘。英国政治中的裂痕不仅关于宗教，也关于，你知道，欧洲有两个大国，你打算与哪一个结盟？博林当然来自法国。她的父亲曾是法国的外交官。而伊丽莎白被认为是一个亲法派，而不是一个亲西班牙派。是的，这是一个问题
because Mary is planning a really spectacular diplomatic coup, namely marriage to the son of the most powerful monarch in the world. And that monarch, of course, is Charles V. And on the 16th of November, Mary announces to Parliament that she is going to be marrying the son of Charles the 5th, Philip of Spain and her admirers think this is an incredible coup. So one of them describes it as the most splendid royal match since the Norman conquest. And in a sense, that's not an exaggeration. I mean, it is an amazing coup. Protestants will see this as a terrible mistake. Mary handing England over to the Catholic superpower. This isn't how Mary sees it. And again, it's a reminder that she's operating in a world where the divisions between Catholic and Protestant,
因为玛丽正在计划一场非常壮观的外交政变，即与世界上最强大的君主的儿子结婚。而那位君主，当然是查理五世。11 月 16 日，玛丽向议会宣布她将嫁给查理五世的儿子，西班牙的菲利普，她的崇拜者认为这是一场令人难以置信的政变。所以其中一个人将其描述为自诺曼征服以来最辉煌的皇室联姻。在某种意义上，这并不夸张。我的意思是，这是一场惊人的政变。新教徒会认为这是一个可怕的错误。玛丽将英国交给了天主教超级大国。这不是玛丽看待它的方式。再次提醒，她是在一个天主教和新教之间的分歧
are not yet set in concrete, because to marry Charles V, who as emperor, rules the low countries, he is the heir of the Dukes of Burgundy. And all that region in the low countries is crucial to the English economy. And it's also crucial as a counterpoint to France. And it's also crucial as an obvious launching pad for any invasion of England. So it has been English policy to side with whoever is ruling the low countries for, for decades and decades and decades. And the fact that Charles V is as powerful as he is,
尚未定型的世界中运作，因为嫁给查理五世，他作为皇帝，统治低地国家，他是勃艮第公爵的继承人。低地国家的所有这些地区对英国经济至关重要。它作为法国的对立面也至关重要。它作为任何入侵英国的明显发射台也至关重要。所以几十年来，英国的政策一直是与统治低地国家的任何人结盟。而查理五世如此强大这一事实，
it seems to Mary and her advisers just makes the deal even better. I mean, basically, it's a traditional Anglo-Bagundian match. And kind of issues of Protestant and Catholic don't really come into the equation, I think, for Mary and her foreign policy advisors. Well, do you remember in our first episode, we described how the marriage of
在玛丽和她的顾问看来，这只会让这笔交易更好。我的意思是，基本上，这是一场传统的英勃联姻。而且新教和天主教的问题，我认为对于玛丽和她的外交政策顾问来说，并没有真正进入等式。嗯，你还记得在我们的第一集中，我们描述了
first Arthur Tudor and then Henry VIII to Catherine of Aragon was an amazing diplomatic coup for Henry the 7th. right, being allied to the emerging superpower of Spain. This is more of the same, but with nobs on. And if you're a patriotic Englishman who thinks smiting the French is the supreme goal of life, what's not to like about this? This is great. Well, I think there is an issue, which of course is that Mary is not a princess. She is a queen. And so there are understandable anxieties, I think for that reason that her marrying Philip may result.
首先是亚瑟·都铎，然后是亨利八世与阿拉贡的凯瑟琳的婚姻，对亨利七世来说是一场惊人的外交政变，对吧，与新兴的西班牙超级大国结盟。这更多是同样的事情，但更进一步。如果你是一个爱国英国人，认为打击法国是人生的最高目标，那么这有什么不好的呢？这太棒了。嗯，我认为有一个问题，当然是玛丽不是公主。她是女王。所以，我认为由于那个原因，人们有可以理解的焦虑，即她嫁给菲利普可能会导致
in England's subordination. I mean, you can see the ruling monarch is the partner of the world's, you know, the son of the world's most powerful man. There is an issue there. And so Mary goes to great lengths to ensure that England will not be subordinated to Phillips' empire. So she prescribes that when he's in England, he has to have kind of Englishmen in his household, not just Spaniards. He's not allowed to have powers of legislation.
英国的从属地位。我的意思是，你可以看到在位君主是世界上，你知道，世界上最强大男人的儿子的伴侣。那里有一个问题。所以玛丽竭尽全力确保英国不会从属于菲利普的帝国。所以她规定，当他在英国时，他的家庭中必须有英国人，而不仅仅是西班牙人。他不被允许拥有立法权。
he is not allowed to embroil England in kind of distant wars. So essentially he has a largely ornamental role. And Philip is actually so offended by this that he almost walks out of the marriage. But for Philip also, France is the great enemy for the Habsburgs. And so for him also, England is a real catch. And so the marriage does go ahead. There's kind of grumbling discontent in Parliament. And I think some of this is tinged by kind of Protestantism.
他不被允许将英国卷入某种遥远的战争。所以本质上，他扮演的角色主要是装饰性的。菲利普实际上对此感到非常冒犯，以至于他差点退出了婚姻。但对于菲利普来说，法国也是哈布斯堡王朝的死敌。所以对他来说，英国也是一个真正的收获。所以婚姻确实进行了。议会中有一些抱怨的不满。我认为其中一些带有一种新教色彩。
But in the main, it's a more kind of brexit-y vibe. kind of, you know, a dislike of any suggestion of foreign influence over England. And surely turbocharged because she's a woman. So Henry VIII was right about one thing. He said, didn't he? The problem with having a daughter succeed me is that she will inevitably fall into the influence of her husband and the kingdom will pass to him. And that must be a huge part of this.
但总的来说，这是一种更像“脱欧”的氛围。你知道，不喜欢任何关于外国对英国影响的暗示。而且肯定因为她是女性而涡轮增压了。所以亨利八世有一件事是对的。他说，不是吗？让女儿继位的问题在于，她不可避免地会陷入丈夫的影响之下，王国将传给他。这一定是其中的重要部分。
That had it been an English king marrying a Spanish princess, the dynamic would be so different. Yeah. But, you know, Mary's Queen. She's a Tudor. She's the daughter of Henry the 8th, and so she's not having any opposition in Parliament at all. So she swats all criticism aside in a very imperious manner. We shall marry as God shall direct our choice to his honour and to our country's good. And again, a very Henry the 8th development. She ponder's disinheriting Elizabeth completely. And of course, Henry the 8th was always doing that. He was always disinheriting his various children. Mary now wants to disinherit her sister because she sees her as two.
如果是一位英国国王娶了一位西班牙公主，动态会非常不同。是的。但是，你知道，玛丽是女王。她是都铎家族的人，是亨利八世的女儿，所以她在议会中根本没有遇到任何反对。所以她以一种非常傲慢的方式拍开了所有的批评。我们将按照上帝指引我们的选择，为了他的荣誉和我们国家的利益而结婚。这又是一个非常亨利八世的发展。她考虑完全剥夺伊丽莎白的继承权。当然，亨利八世总是那样做。他总是剥夺他各个孩子的继承权。玛丽现在想剥夺她妹妹的继承权，因为她认为她太
heretical, too popular with the mass of the people. She suspects her of being in league with the French. There are all kinds of good reasons. It seems to marry. But her counsels say this would be a really, really bad idea. So as one of them puts it, since Parliament had accepted the Lady Elizabeth as proper to succeed, it would be difficult to deprive her of the right she claimed without causing trouble. And what does he mean by trouble? Well, there are those you know, 2,000 horsemen, there's the fact that Elizabeth is the second largest landowner in the country. Let sleeping dogs lie is basically the advice. So Mary does, but of course she remains very suspicious of her. And all the more so, because the marriage with Philip is
异端，在广大人民中太受欢迎。她怀疑她与法国人勾结。在玛丽看来，有各种各样的好理由。但她的顾问们说，这将是一个非常、非常糟糕的主意。所以正如其中一人所说，既然议会已经接受伊丽莎白夫人为合适的继位者，那么在不引起麻烦的情况下剥夺她所声称的权利将是困难的。他所说的麻烦是什么意思？嗯，有那些，你知道，2,000 名骑兵，有伊丽莎白是该国第二大土地所有者的事实。让沉睡的狗躺着，基本上就是建议。所以玛丽照做了，但当然她仍然非常怀疑她。而且更是如此，因为与菲利普的婚姻是
unpopular for the reasons that we've been saying. And, you know, she's nervous about whether Elizabeth might be kind of causing trouble. So Elizabeth, by December, is aware that she is really not flavour of the month with Mary. And so she decides to withdraw from London, withdraw from the court, and she goes back to Hatfield and hunkers down there. And at the same time as she does this, in closed rooms across the capital, across the south of England and into the Midlands,
不受欢迎的，原因正如我们所说。而且，你知道，她很紧张伊丽莎白是否可能在制造麻烦。所以伊丽莎白到 12 月时意识到她真的不是玛丽眼中的红人。所以她决定撤出伦敦，撤出宫廷，回到哈特菲尔德并躲在那里。与此同时，在首都、英格兰南部和中部地区的封闭房间里，
conspirators are starting to plot rebellion. And the object of these conspirators is to depose Mary and to replace her with Elizabeth. And the man who gives his name to this plot is a kind of young, dashing blade called Sir Thomas Wyatt, the son of the man who introduced the sonnet into England. He's a very experienced soldier, he's a Protestant, and he loathes the Spanish,
阴谋家们开始策划叛乱。这些阴谋家的目标是废黜玛丽，并以伊丽莎白取而代之。这个阴谋的领头人是一位年轻、潇洒的剑客，名叫托马斯·怀亚特爵士，他正是那位将十四行诗引入英国的人的儿子。他是一位经验丰富的军人，也是一名新教徒，他非常厌恶西班牙人，
because his father, as well as bringing the sonnet into England, had also been an ambassador to Spain. And so the young Thomas had been there and had seen the Inquisition doing its son. stuff and had fully brought into the idea of Spain as a kind of a nest of Catholic tyrants. And because he's a swashbuckling charismatic character, Wyatt, everyone calls this Wyatt's rebellion. But actually, it's kind of Lady Jane Grey, too, isn't it? Yeah. So, for example, Lady Jane Grey's father, the Duke of Suffolk, is involved with this.
因为他的父亲不仅将十四行诗引入了英国，还曾担任驻西班牙大使。因此，年轻的托马斯曾去过那里，亲眼目睹了宗教裁判所的所作所为，并完全接受了“西班牙是天主教暴君巢穴”的观点。由于怀亚特是一个风流倜傥、极具魅力的人物，大家都称之为“怀亚特叛乱”。但实际上，这似乎也与简·格雷夫人有关，不是吗？是的。例如，简·格雷夫人的父亲萨福克公爵也参与其中。
And there's lots of people who are basically, they've found themselves out in the cold since Mary took over. It's kind of your classic Tudor faction fight to some degree, isn't it? Yes, and as Nicola Talas in her book on Young Elizabeth points out, the conspirators were all well connected, and they all had contacts within Elizabeth's household. And this will be a key issue in how this rebellion plays out. So the plan of these conspirators, Wyatt and his co-conspirators, is to raise the country on Palm Sunday, 1554. Wyatt will raise Kent. the Duke of Suffolk will raise the Midlands and the other uprisings are planned in the West Country
还有许多人基本上在玛丽继位后就失势了。在某种程度上，这算是典型的都铎王朝派系斗争，对吧？是的，正如尼古拉·塔拉斯在她的《年轻的伊丽莎白》一书中所指出的，这些阴谋家都人脉广泛，且在伊丽莎白的府邸内都有联系人。这将是这场叛乱如何演变的关键问题。因此，这些阴谋家——怀亚特和他的同谋者——的计划是在1554年的棕枝主日发动全国起义。怀亚特将发动肯特郡，萨福克公爵将发动中部地区，其他起义则计划在西部地区，
and tellingly in Hertfordshire, which is where Hatfield House, Elizabeth's base is. But news of this conspiracy leaks well, well before Palm Sunday. So Palm Sunday is the Sunday before Easter. Already by January 1554, news of what's being plotted is starting to reach the ears of Mary's spies.
以及赫特福德郡，这里是伊丽莎白的基地哈特菲尔德庄园所在地。但这个阴谋的消息在棕枝主日之前很久就泄露了。棕枝主日是复活节前的那个星期日。早在1554年1月，阴谋的消息就已经开始传到玛丽的间谍耳中了。
And so all the uprisings are suppressed, really before they can kick off, except for one. And that is Wyatt's uprising in Kent. So there he has raised about 3,000 men. Most of them are Protestant. They march on London. It's very reminiscent of the Peasants' Revolt. They are unable to cross London Bridge, but they go down to Kingston, swing back and try to enter London through the Western Gates. And as they're approaching, Mary is urged to flee. But instead, she rides. to the Guildhall and she rallies the city and she declares herself married to her people
因此，所有的起义实际上在爆发前就被镇压了，只有一个例外，那就是肯特郡的怀亚特起义。他在那里召集了大约3000人。他们大多数是新教徒。他们向伦敦进军。这非常让人想起农民起义。他们无法穿过伦敦桥，于是转而前往金斯顿，绕回来试图通过西门进入伦敦。当他们逼近时，有人敦促玛丽逃跑。但她没有，她骑马前往市政厅，召集市民，并宣布她已与她的人民结为婚姻，
and a contemporary witness describes the performance she puts on and is very impressed. More than Marvel it was to see that day the invincible heart and constancy of the queen herself who being by nature or woman and therefore commonly more fearful than men be showed herself in that case more stout than is credible. That's impressive and that's very
一位当时的目击者描述了她的表现，并留下了深刻印象。那天，人们看到女王本人那不可战胜的心志和坚定不移的毅力，真是令人惊叹。她身为女性，本应比男人更胆怯，但在那种情况下，她表现出的坚毅令人难以置信。这令人印象深刻，而且非常
that's very Tudor and Tom, it's very Elizabeth the first at Tilbury, you know? It's very Elizabeth the first. And so again and again, when you read about how Mary kind of plays the role of a queen, you realize that she's providing a role model that Elizabeth, I think, undoubtedly kind of remembered. It's very Elizabeth at Tilbury. It's the second time she's done this in a year, right? I mean, she did it during the Lady Jane Grey business. This is Lady Jane Grey, too, basically. Yeah. And once again, the people are with her. They are. Yeah. They rally and support Mary. Wyatt's rebellion is crushed and Mary who I think naturally is kind-hearted she is widely thought
这非常都铎，汤姆，这非常像在蒂尔伯里的伊丽莎白一世，你知道吗？这非常伊丽莎白一世。所以，当你一次又一次地读到玛丽如何扮演女王的角色时，你会意识到她提供了一个榜样，我想伊丽莎白无疑是记住了这一点。这非常像蒂尔伯里的伊丽莎白。这是她一年内第二次这样做，对吧？我的意思是，她在简·格雷夫人事件中也这样做过。这基本上也是简·格雷夫人的事。是的。人民再次站在她这一边。他们确实站在她这边。是的。他们团结起来支持玛丽。怀亚特叛乱被镇压了，而玛丽，我认为她天性善良，人们普遍认为
to be of a merciful disposition but she feels she has no choice now but to you know firm smack of government so Wyatt is executed the Duke of Suffolk is executed because the Duke of Suffolk is Lady Jane Grey's father that means that Lady Jane Grey has to be executed Guilford has to be executed a hundred of Wyatt's followers are hanged And in London, the Imperial Ambassador reports one sees nothing but gibbets and hanged men. Oh, Mary's brilliant, isn't she? It's such a shame she let herself down about the Pope because in every other respect. Her choices are great.
她心地仁慈，但她觉得现在别无选择，只能采取强硬的政府手段。所以怀亚特被处决了，萨福克公爵被处决了，因为萨福克公爵是简·格雷夫人的父亲，这意味着简·格雷夫人必须被处决，吉尔福德也必须被处决，怀亚特的一百名追随者被绞死。在伦敦，帝国大使报告说，到处都是绞刑架和被绞死的人。哦，玛丽很出色，不是吗？真可惜她在教皇问题上让自己失望了，因为在其他方面，她的选择都很棒。
She's nice. She's a merciful person, but she does what she has to do, and I applaud her for it. Well, so she has smacked down the rebellion. But, of course, there is one massive question that is left hanging, and that is what in this rebellion was the role of Elizabeth and of course this is investigated immediately and Elizabeth is a very shrewd operator already she's not the woman who is going to leave incriminating evidence around if she had been involved in the plot which I think she probably had been and I think the most salient piece of evidence that she had at least been complicit in the plot is that the husband of her
她人很好。她是一个仁慈的人，但她做了她必须做的事，我为她鼓掌。好吧，她镇压了叛乱。但是，当然，留下了一个巨大的悬而未决的问题，那就是伊丽莎白在这场叛乱中扮演了什么角色？当然，这立即受到了调查，而伊丽莎白已经是一个非常精明的操作者了。如果她参与了阴谋，她绝不会留下任何确凿的证据，尽管我认为她可能参与了。我认为她至少参与了阴谋的最显著证据是，她最宠爱的凯特·阿什利的丈夫约翰·阿什利在叛乱后逃往国外。他为什么要那样做？据推测，他一直是一个中间人。我的意思是，这似乎是对正在发生的事情最合理的解释。这可能不像她说“让我们除掉我姐姐，我想当女王”那么直接。可能只是她说，“好吧，听着，让我们看看会发生什么。”而且，你知道，如果事情……我随时准备着，你知道，
great favorite cat Ashley, John Ashley, in the wake of the rebellion, he flees abroad. And why is he doing that? Presumably, he had been a kind of go-between. I mean, it's, it seems the likeless explanation for what's going on. And it might not be as straightforward as her saying, let's get rid of my sister and I'd like to be queen. It may be her just saying, well, listen, let's see what happens. And I'm, you know, I'm available if things, you know,
是的，如果球在争球后方滚落出来。是的，完全正确，完全正确。所以她受到了审讯，当然她坚称自己无辜，而玛丽不相信她。因此，1月26日，玛丽传唤伊丽莎白前往伦敦，伊丽莎白经典地回答说：“哦，我感觉有点不舒服，有点头痛，有点感冒”，并拒绝前往。于是玛丽在2月12日派出一队出身高贵的代理人，比如勋爵们等等，前往哈特菲尔德把她带回伦敦。玛丽这次特意派了两名医生，以确保她不能装病。所以旅程花了很长时间，因为伊丽莎白一直说：“哦，我头痛。我不能去，等等。”但最终，
Yeah, if the ball comes loose at the back of the scrum. Yeah, exactly, exactly. So she gets interrogated, and of course she protests her innocence, and Mary doesn't believe her. So on the 26th of January, Mary summons Elizabeth to come to London, and Elizabeth classically says, oh, I feel a bit ill, I've got a bit of a headache, a bit of a cold, and refuses to come. So Mary then sends a posse of very well-born agents, kind of lords and so on, on the 12th of February, to go to hat for. field and bring her back to London. And Mary makes sure this time to send two doctors to make sure that, you know, she can't pull a sickie. And so the journey takes a very long time because Elizabeth continues to say, oh, I've got a headache. I can't go, whatever. But finally,
他们到达了。伊丽莎白在白厅下车。一大群人聚集在那里看她。他们为她欢呼。伊丽莎白被带进白厅的私人住所，她不被允许见玛丽。几周过去了，伊丽莎白一直心想：天哪，发生了什么事？他们找到任何确凿的证据了吗？他们在伪造证据吗？我的意思是，谁知道她在想什么，但她对即将降临到自己头上的事情感到紧张。然后在3月16日，她知道了。她受到了大法官和其他19名议会成员的拜访。那大约是玛丽议会的一半人。这非常像安妮·博林的情况，对吧？非常像安妮·博林。而且伊丽莎白即将经历的一切，几乎每一件事
they arrive. And Elizabeth gets out at Whitehall. A large crowd has gathered to see her. They cheer her. Elizabeth is taken into Whitehall, a private quarters, she's not allowed to see Mary, the weeks pass, and all the time Elizabeth is thinking, oh my God, what's going on? Have they found any incriminating evidence? Are they faking evidence? I mean, you knows what she's thinking, but she is nervous about what might be about to hit her. And then on the 16th of March, she finds out. So she is visited by the Lord Chancellor and 19 other things. council members. So that's about half Mary's council. This is very Anne Berlin. This is what happened to her, right? Very Anne Boleyn. And almost everything about what Elizabeth is going to go through
都让人想起安妮·博林。而且我认为这是故意的。玛丽在和她玩心理游戏。所以议员们询问她与怀亚特叛乱的牵连。反复询问她已经被问过的问题。她再次否认了所有参与。议员们再次表现出公开的怀疑。伊丽莎白要求见玛丽，以便为自己辩护。这个请求被拒绝了。她再次坚持自己的清白。她说：“我是一个女人。我在思想、言语和行为上都是一个真正的女人。”审讯者打断了她。他们用伊丽莎白从被从哈特菲尔德带到伦敦的那一刻起就一定一直担心的词语回答了她。
is reminiscent of Anne Boleyn. And I think deliberately so. Mary is playing mind games with her. So the councillors question her about her involvement with Wyatt's rebellion. Going over questions, she has already been asked. And once again, she denies all involvement in it. And once again, the councillors display open skepticism. Elizabeth demands to be brought into Mary's presence so that she can plead her case. This request is refused. Again, she insists on her innocence. She says, I am a woman. I am a true woman in thought, word and deed. And her interrogators cut her off. And they answer her with words that Elizabeth must surely have been dreading from the moment that she was fetched from Hatfield and brought to London.
议员们用绝对是为了让安妮·博林的女儿感到恐惧的词语告诉她：“女王陛下已完全决定，你必须去伦敦塔。”真是个悬念。年轻的伊丽莎白到底会发生什么？休息后揭晓。本集由优步赞助。现在，你知道当有人在你最需要的时候为你挺身而出的那种感觉吗？
The counsellors tell her in words that were absolutely calculated to fill the daughter of Anne Boleyn with dread, there is no remedy for that the Queen's Majesty is fully determined that you should go unto the tower. What a cliffhanger. What on earth is going to happen to the young Elizabeth? Find out after the break. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most?
我们有时都需要那样，优步知道这一点。优步不仅仅是乘车或送餐。它是无论如何都会为你挺身而出。就像为你远方的朋友，在他们生病时送去汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。当它真正重要时，无论是什么，你都会挺身而出。有志者，事竟成，我们在路上。优步，我们在路上。
We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way.
立即下载该应用程序。直到此刻，我在上帝面前抗议，上帝将评判我的真诚，无论恶意如何设计，我从未策划、建议或同意任何可能以任何方式损害你的人身安全或以任何方式危及国家的事情。因此，我谦卑地恳求陛下让我亲自回答，不要让我去依赖你的议员们。是的。如果可能的话，在我去伦敦塔之前，如果不行，在我被进一步定罪之前。所以这是一个非凡的呼吁。它是写于
Download the app today. To this present hour I protest before God, who shall judge my truth whatsoever malice shall devise, that I never practiced counsel nor consented to anything that might be prejudicial to your person in any way or dangerous to the state by any means. And therefore I humbly beseech your majesty to let me answer for yourself and not suffer me to trust to your counsellors, yay. And that afore I go to the tower if it be possible, if not before I be further condemned. So that's an extraordinary appeal. And it was written on
3月17日，由伊丽莎白写给她的姐姐玛丽。她正在等待守卫将她从白厅沿泰晤士河带到伦敦塔。她显然非常害怕自己会遭受与她母亲安妮·博林一样的命运，安妮·博林曾被囚禁在伦敦塔，然后被斩首。她恳求玛丽能让她直接为自己辩护，正如安妮·博林曾恳求能为自己向亨利八世辩护一样。正如我们所知，情况看起来
the 17th March by Elizabeth to her sister Mary. She is waiting. for guards to move her from Whitehall up the River Thames to the Tower of London. She is obviously terrified that she is going to suffer the same fate as her mother, Anne Boleyn, who was imprisoned in the tower and then beheaded. She is begging Mary to be able to plead her case directly to her, exactly as Anne Boleyn had begged that she would be able to plead her case to Henry VIII. and as we know things are looking
对她来说极其黯淡。她被武装看守，与仆人隔绝，第二天，两名议会成员到了，不是吗？要把她带到伦敦塔，看起来她已经大势已去了。是的，我认为这是她一生中最绝望的时刻。
incredibly bleak for her she's been put under armed guard she's been separated from her servants and then the next day two members of the council arrived don't they to take her to the tower and it looks as though the game is up for her yeah I think it's the most desperate moment of her life
所以，前来带她去伦敦塔的两名议会成员都是绝对的重量级人物。其中一个是叫威廉·波莱特的人，他是温彻斯特侯爵，他非常苍老，非常灰白，而且，正如伊丽莎白很清楚的那样，他曾是安妮·博林所谓情人们审判的法官之一。另一个人叫亨利·拉德克利夫，他是萨塞克斯伯爵。
so the two members of the council who arrive to take her to the tower are absolute heavyweights so one of them is a guy called William Paulett who is the Marquist of Winchester he's very grizzled he's very grey and he, as Elizabeth would have known for well, had been one of the judges at the trial of Anne Boleyn's supposed lovers. The other is a man called Henry Rackcliffe, and he is the Earl of Sussex.
他四十多岁，是伊丽莎白的叔祖父。所以伊丽莎白转向他，恳求他：“请让我见见我姐姐。”萨塞克斯说：“不，陛下已经绝对拒绝了。”于是伊丽莎白说：“好吧，请问我可以给女王写封信吗？”于是萨塞克斯，你知道，他是叔祖父。他可能比温彻斯特侯爵更倾向于她。他说：“好吧，你可以写一封信。”于是伊丽莎白坐下来，匆匆写下，抗议自己的清白，警告玛丽要提防所有诽谤她的人。令人惊讶的是，她甚至引用了托马斯·西摩的例子，她那位非常英俊的继父，我们在上一集谈到过他。是的，挠痒痒先生。
He is in his mid-forties, and he is Elizabeth's great-uncle. And so Elizabeth turns to him and begs him, please let me see my sister. Sussex says, no, Her Majesty has absolutely refused that. And so then Elizabeth says, well, please, may I write the queen a letter? And so Sussex, you know, he's a great uncle. He's more favourably disposed to her, perhaps, than the Marquis of Winchester. He says, all right, you can write a letter. And so Elizabeth sits down and she scribbles away, protesting her innocence, warning Mary to stand guard against all those who would slander her. And astonishingly, she even cites the example of Thomas Seymour, her very hansy stepfather, who we talked about in the previous episode. Yeah, Mr. Tickle.
她写信给玛丽：“近日，我听到萨默塞特勋爵说，如果他的兄弟被允许与他交谈，他就永远不会受苦。”这是一个令人惊叹的说法，将自己比作托马斯·西摩，将玛丽比作托马斯·西摩的哥哥萨默塞特公爵。因为考虑到流言蜚语，我的意思是，这是一种疯狂的类比，可能反映了她所承受的压力程度。你像对待杰弗里·爱泼斯坦一样对待我。是的。是的。是的。我的意思是，这对她来说不是明智的话。但她足够机灵，当她写完一整页，然后在第二页写了一半时，她在名字下面划了一条线，并划掉了后面的空白，这样人们就无法在她说的话下面伪造东西。这花了很多时间，
She writes to Mary, in late days, I heard my Lord of Somerset say that if his brother had been suffered to speak with him, he had never suffered. And it's kind of an amazing thing to say, comparing herself to Thomas Seymour and Mary to Thomas Seymour's elder brother, the Duke of Somers. set. Because in view of the gossip, I mean, that's a kind of mad illusion to make and may be reflective of the degree of stress that she's under. You're treating me like Jeffrey Epstein. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, not a sensible thing for her to say. But she's sufficiently on the ball that when she has, you know, she writes a whole page and then she covers a halfway down at a second page. And then she scores a line underneath her name and does lines through it so that people won't be able to kind of fake things underneath what she said. And this takes so much time
以至于潮水一直在上涨。当她写完时，潮水已经涨得太高，以至于无法再通过伦敦桥了。因此，去伦敦塔的行程不得不推迟一天。这是伊丽莎白一生中一直最喜欢的策略之一的经典例子，当她被逼入绝境时，本质上就是拖延、推诿、敷衍。然而，你知道，一天过去了。第二天九点，棕枝主日，温彻斯特和萨塞克斯再次出现。当然，这一天正是怀亚特叛乱原定爆发的日子。玛丽没有任何回应。她没有回复伊丽莎白的信。所以伊丽莎白听天由命了。如果没有补救办法，
that all the while the tide has been rising. And by the time she's finished, the tide has risen so high that it will no longer be possible to pass under London Bridge. And so the journey to the tower has to be postponed for a day. And this is a classic example of what will throughout her life be one of Elizabeth's favorite tactics when she's cornered, which is essentially just to delay, to prevaricate, to string people along. However, you know, day passes. And at nine the next day, Palm Sunday, Winchester and Sussex reappear. And this is the day, of course, that White's rebellion had been scheduled for. There is nothing from Mary. She doesn't reply to Elizabeth's letter. And so Elizabeth is resigned to her fate. If there be no remedy,
她说，那么我必须满足。于是她上了船。她被划船沿河向上游向伦敦塔。外面下着倾盆大雨。船穿过伦敦桥，他们停靠在伦敦塔并系好船。根据约翰·福克斯的说法，他在极大的爱和细节中描述了这一切，她被划船到了叛徒门。她起初拒绝下船。当她最终下船时，她宣布：“这里登陆的是一位最忠诚的臣民，
she says, then I must be contented. So she gets into the boat. She's rowed up the river towards the tower. It's bucketing down with rain. Underneath London Bridge, the boat goes, and they pull up to the tower and more there. And according to John Fox, who describes all this in great and loving detail, she was rowed up to the traitor's gate. And she initially, she refused to get out of the boat. And then when she did so, she declared, here landeth as true a subject.
作为囚犯，曾经在这级台阶上登陆过。”这成了一个非常著名的场景，著名的台词。然而，我们从一位当时的目击者那里得知，这并没有发生，实际上她是穿过吊桥进入伦敦塔的，所以她下了船，从正门进入。我认为这对伊丽莎白来说同样令人不寒而栗，因为那是她母亲安妮·博林进入伦敦塔的同一个入口。当伊丽莎白进入伦敦塔时，她会看到她的表亲简·格雷夫人刚刚被处决的脚手架，那正是她母亲被处决的地方。当她被带到她的住所时，那是她父亲为她母亲的加冕礼重建的皇家住所，安妮一直待在那里直到她被处决的那一刻。所以巨大的心理压力，而且我认为完全是故意的。部分原因，你知道，你问，玛丽是在为安妮·博林的幽灵复仇吗？我认为在某种程度上她是。但我认为她这样做也是因为她需要伊丽莎白崩溃。她需要伊丽莎白认罪，因为如果伊丽莎白不认罪，那么就没有什么确凿的证据反对她。这真的很重要，因为，你知道，重申一下，伊丽莎白非常受欢迎。
being prisoner, has ever landed at these stairs. And this becomes a kind of famous, famous scene, famous lines. However, we know from a contemporary witness that this didn't happen, that actually she entered the tower across the drawbridge, so she got out of the boat and entered through the main entrance. And I think this would have been no less chilling for Elizabeth, because that is the same gateway through which her mother, Anne Boleyn, had entered the tower. And when Elizabeth passed inside the tower, she would have seen the scaffolding on which Lady Jane Gray, her cousin, had just been executed, and that had been built on the very spot where her mother had been executed. And when she is led to her quarters, these are the royal quarters which her father had
她本身就是一个非常有权势的人物。玛丽在没有极其确凿证据的情况下起诉自己的妹妹是非常危险的。而且伊丽莎白，我想，可能很自信没有确凿的证据反对她。所以当她在耶稣受难日被带到议会面前时，很快就很清楚他们并没有真正掌握她的任何把柄。话虽如此，亨利八世，亨利八世无疑会处决她。我的意思是，他不需要确凿的证据。他编造了证据。但玛丽并不那么反复无常。我想对于一个女人来说，你知道，可能更难确定自己可以像亨利八世那样随意编造东西。
rebuilt for her mother's coronation and where Anne had stayed until the hour of her execution. So massive psychological pressure, and I think completely deliberate. partly, you know, you asked, is Mary avenging herself on the ghost of Anne Boleyn? I think to a degree here she is. But I think she's also doing it because she needs Elizabeth to break. She needs Elizabeth to confess, because if Elizabeth doesn't confess, then there isn't really any hard evidence against her. And this really matters because, you know, just to reiterate, Elizabeth is very popular.
是的，我认为她的地位不如亨利稳定。完全正确。所以存在危险，不是吗？怀亚特。他还在现场。他将于4月11日被处决。她心中一定有一些怀疑，一些恐惧，基本上他会出现在断头台上说：“是伊丽莎白让我这么做的。”但她是其中的一部分。
She is a very powerful figure in her own right. it would be very dangerous for Mary to prosecute her own sister without extremely solid evidence. And Elizabeth, I think, probably, is probably confident that there isn't hard evidence against her. And so when she's brought before the council on Good Friday, it soon becomes very clear that they haven't really got anything on her. That said, in Henry VIII, Henry VIII, would undoubtedly have executed her. I mean, he didn't need hard evidence. He made it up. But Mary is not quite as capricious. And I guess for a woman, you know, it's hard, maybe harder to be quite so secure that you can just make stuff up as Henry the 8th was.
她一直都知道这件事。但他故意没有那样做。他为什么不那样做？因为这不是真的，或者他是一个善良的人？好吧，他明确表示：“伊丽莎白在我开始之前并没有参与我的起义或骚乱。”对。我想有两种解释。第一，伊丽莎白确实没有参与。
Yeah, I think her position is less stable than Henry's. Exactly. So there is a danger, isn't there? Wyatt. He's still on the scene. And he's going to be executed on 11th of April. And there must have been some doubt in her mind, some fear that basically he turns up on the scaffold and says, Elizabeth made me do it. But she was part of it.
是的。他在说实话。第二，你知道，他期待着玛丽有一位新教继承人的前景。他想让她留在游戏中。所以我想任何一种解释都是充分的。所以最终，她，你知道，威胁消退了，对吧？她在那里又待了一个月。又是一个月的犹豫不决。
She knew about it all along. But he deliberately doesn't do that. Why doesn't you do it? Because it's not true, or he's a kind person? Well, he explicitly says, Elizabeth had not been privy of my rising or commotion before I began. Right. I suppose there are two explanations for that. One, Elizabeth hadn't been privy to it.
好吧，玛丽和议会推诿，他们正在讨论如何处理她。然后，这又是对过去的一点致意吗？所以是在5月19日的下午，也就是安妮·博林被处决的周年纪念日，伊丽莎白被允许离开伦敦塔。你认为那是故意的还是不是？我相信是的。
Yeah. He's telling the truth. Secondly, you know, he's looking forward to the prospect of a Protestant heir to Mary. And he wants to keep her in the game. So either explanation, I think, would be adequate. So eventually, she, you know, the threat recedes, right? She's there for another month. There's another month of dithering.
对。我认为安妮·博林的命运在整个这一集中回响如此明显，不可能是巧合。但在这里信息不同。信息是：你母亲最终上了断头台，但你被饶恕了。这难道不证明你姐姐是多么善良和仁慈吗？
Well, Mary and the council prevaricate and they're discussing what to do with her. And then, again, is this a little nod to the past? So it's on the afternoon of the 19th of May, which is the anniversary of Anne Boleyn's execution that Elizabeth is allowed out of the tower. Do you think that was deliberately chosen or not? I'm sure it was.
你不觉得那是信息吗？不，我不这么认为。所以伊丽莎白被从伦敦塔释放，但她仍然是一名囚犯。所以她被划船沿河而下，而不是被允许穿过伦敦城，在那里她可能会受到欢呼。而玛丽，我认为，基本上是在说，
Right. I think the echoes of Anne Boleyn's fate throughout this entire episode are so manifest that it can't be coincidental. But here the message is different. The message is your mother ended up in the chopping block, but you are being spared. And doesn't that prove how nice and merciful your sister is?
你知道，我还在盯着你。是的。你母亲的命运仍然悬在你的脖子上。不要怀疑这一点。伊丽莎白没有被关在伦敦。玛丽显然想把她埋在乡下的荒野里。所以她被送到了你所在的地区，牛津郡，具体来说是伍德斯托克宫，非常接近今天的布伦海姆。
Don't you think that's the message? No, I don't. So Elizabeth is being freed from the tower, but she's still a prisoner. So she's rowed down the river rather than being allowed to pass through the city of London where she might be cheered. And Mary, I think, is basically saying,
伍德斯托克对王室来说是一个非常重要的地方。它是黑太子出生的地方。它是亨利七世庆祝阿拉贡的凯瑟琳与亚瑟王子订婚的地方。所以，也许又是某种心理战，那可能有点夸大其词了。设计用来摧毁伊丽莎白的是，到那时，伍德斯托克已经变得非常破旧。所以它非常破败，潮湿，有干腐病，我想，你知道，到处都是福米卡，那种可怕的1970年代
you know, I've still got my eye on you. Yeah. The fate of your mother is still kind of hovering over your neck. Don't doubt that. Elizabeth is not kept a prisoner in London. Mary obviously wants her kind of buried in the wilds of the countryside. And so she is sent to your neck of the woods, to Oxfordshire, and specifically Woodstock Palace, so very near what's today is Blenheim.
壁纸，你知道，如果你像伊丽莎白那样出身高贵，那不是你想待的地方。所以她绝对讨厌它。她很无聊。
Woodstock had been a very significant. could place for the royal family. So it's where the black prince had been born. It's where Henry the 7th had celebrated the betrothal of Catherine of Aragon to Prince Arthur. So again, perhaps another piece of kind of psychological warfare there, that might be kind of over-egging it. What is clearly designed to break Elizabeth is the fact that by this point, Woodstock has become very dilapidated. So it's very rundown, it's damp, there's dry rot, I guess, kind of, you know, full mica everywhere, kind of terrible 1970s
她被孤立了。她被禁止，我引用，“任何来自或发往任何人的信息、信件或信物。”看，任何类型的人，
wallpaper, you know, not the kind of place that you'd want to stay if you are as highborn as Elizabeth is. And so she absolutely hates it. She's bored.
但这不属实。有一种人是她被允许接触的，汤姆。那是一个威尔士人。最近节目里有很多威尔士历史。有些人会说太多了。所以解释一下威尔士是如何再次出现的。所以托马斯·帕里，被大卫·斯塔基描述为一个肥胖、自以为是的威尔士人。他是伊丽莎白的代理人，你知道，她的财务规划师，那个，你知道，她的会计。他被允许
She's isolated. She's forbidden, and I quote, any message, letter or token to or from any manner of person. See, any manner of person,
与伊丽莎白接触，因为伊丽莎白必须支付她自己的监禁费用。所以他必须找到使伊丽莎白能够做到这一点的钱。于是他把自己安置在当地的酒吧里。在那里，他能够充当伊丽莎白观察世界的窗口。天哪，这个节目里有太多的威尔士历史了。必须说，伍德斯托克的窗户真的不是被困在后面让人愉快的东西。根据福克斯的说法，这又是他讲述的一个著名故事。伊丽莎白有一枚钻石戒指，她用它在其中一块玻璃窗格上刻下了诗句。“多被我怀疑，无一事可证，引述，伊丽莎白，囚犯。”
but that's not true. There is one manner of person that she is allowed contact with Tom. And that's a Welshman. There's a lot of Welsh history on the show these days. Some would say too much. So explain how Wales features yet again. So Thomas Parry, described by David Starkey, as a fat, self-important Welshman. He is Elizabeth's agent, you know, her financial planner, the guy who, you know, her accountant. And he is allowed
你认为那真的发生了吗？人们找到过那块窗玻璃吗？我认为它可能发生了。我要说的是，它读起来像是伊丽莎白可能写下的诗句，因为我们有很多伊丽莎白的诗。好的。与此同时，在伍德斯托克的窗外，玛丽正在进行她的反革命，
contact with Elizabeth because Elizabeth has to pay for her own imprisonment. And so he has to find the money that enables Elizabeth to do this. And so he installs himself in the bull, the local pub. And there he's able to serve as Elizabeth's window on the world. God, so much Welsh history in this show. It has to be said, the windows of Woodstock are really not fun things to be stuck behind. And according to Fox, again, this is a famous story that he tells. Elizabeth has a diamond ring, and she uses this to scratch lines of poetry on one of the panes of glass. Much suspected by me, nothing proved can be, quote, Elizabeth, prisoner.
尽管她并不认为这是反革命。她认为这是家务事。这就是福克斯在他的《殉道者之书》中描述的“血腥玛丽统治下的巨大暴政”，即绞刑、斩首、焚烧和监禁。这是英国历史上曾经所有男孩和女孩在11岁之前都学过的一集，那是英国故事中最黑暗的时期，当时血腥玛丽和她的天主教暴君试图烧毁真正的宗教。
Do you think that really happened? Have people found their pain of the window pain? I think it probably happened. What I will say is it reads like lines that Elizabeth might have written because we have quite a lot of Elizabeth's poetry. Okay. Now, meanwhile, outside the windows of Woodstock, Mary is proceeding with her counter-revolution,
是的。而且，我的意思是，很多人确实死了，不是吗？大约300名新教徒被烧死在火刑柱上。是的。所以针对血腥玛丽的指控清单，多亏了福克斯，非常长，其中一些300名殉道者是非常著名的人，所以其中一个是托马斯·克兰默，他曾是坎特伯雷大主教，当然也是安妮·博林在成为大主教之前的牧师，并且是伊丽莎白的教父。另一个
even though she doesn't think of it as a counter-revolution. She thinks of it as housekeeping. And this is what Fox describes in his book of martyrs as the great tyranny of Bloody Mary's reign, so the hanging, beheading, burning and prisoning. And this is the episode in English history that once upon a time, all boys and girls learned before the age of about 11 years old, the kind of darkest period in, you know, the story of England when Bloody Mary and her Catholic tyrants sought to burn out the true religion.
是爱德华六世统治下的伦敦主教，一个叫尼古拉斯·里德利的人，他在简·格雷夫人为女王的那段时间里，他曾反对玛丽和伊丽莎白，称她们为私生女，并说简是合法的女王。所以伊丽莎白可能像玛丽一样享受他的殉道。是的。这是牛津的殉道者纪念碑。你至今仍能看到它。
Yeah. And, I mean, a lot of people do die, don't they? 300 or so Protestants are burned at the stake. Yeah. So the charge sheet against Bloody Mary is, thanks to Fox, very much. lengthy and some of these 300 martyrs are very famous men so one of them is Thomas Cranmer who'd been Archbishop of Canterbury and of course Ambelin's chaplain before he became Archbishop and had been Elizabeth's godfather another
是的。但也有，这些是大人物，但也有很多普通的无名小卒被处决，不是吗？所以著名的是，有很多裁缝等等在伦敦城外的史密斯菲尔德被烧死。你可以在圣巴塞洛缪医院的侧面看到他们的纪念碑。还有一个臭名昭著的事件发生在海峡群岛的根西岛，当时一名孕妇被送上火刑架。引用伍丁的话，在火焰中，她生下了一个男婴，被旁观者救出。但当时在场的法警
is the guy who'd been the Bishop of London under Edward the 6th a man called Nicholas Ridley and he had in the the spell when Lady Jane Grey was Queen he had preached against both Mary and Elizabeth Elizabeth, calling them bastards and saying that Jane was the rightful queen. So Elizabeth might have enjoyed his martyrdom almost as much as Mary did. Yeah. This is the martyrs memorial in Oxford. You can see it to this day.
把他推回火中，与他的母亲一起丧生。当你读到那个时，你会认为那一定是宣传。我不敢相信那发生了。但我们知道它发生了，因为法警后来在伊丽莎白统治下因谋杀儿童而被起诉。所以那确实发生了。这就是血腥玛丽。但宣传也将玛丽描绘成一个政治失败者。这份指控清单上的证据A是她与西班牙菲利普的婚姻。论点是，通过这样做，玛丽使英国从属于一个专横的外国教皇信徒，而且还是个西班牙人。
Yeah. But there are also, these are the bigwigs, but they're also very ordinary unsung people who are executed, aren't there? So famously, there are lots kind of tailors and so on who were burned in Smithfield, just outside the city of London. And you can see a memorial to them there on the side of St. Bartholome. Mews Hospital. And there's one notorious episode which happened on Guernsey in the Channel Islands when a pregnant woman is consigned to the flames. And to quote Wooding, amidst the flames, she gave birth to a baby boy who was rescued by a bystander. But the bailiff in
结果除了羞辱什么都没有。英国被拖入了一场与她无关的法国战争。这在1588年1月以加来的屈辱性丢失而告终，加来是自爱德华三世以来英国在欧洲大陆的立足点。而且，又是那个每个人都曾经知道的著名故事，玛丽在临终时说：“当我死后被剖开，你会发现加来躺在我的心里。”而且，你知道，这是玛丽作为失败者和偏执狂的形象。但是汤姆，现在我们不是在修正主义。我的意思是，
attendance thrust him back into the fire to perish with his mother. And when you read that, you think that must be propaganda. I can't believe that happened. But we know that it did because the bailiff was subsequently prosecuted for the murder of the child under Elizabeth. So that did happen. So that's bloody Mary. But the propaganda also casts Mary as a political failure. And Exhibit A on this charge sheet is her marriage to Philip of Spain. And the argument is that by doing this, Mary has subordinated England to a domineering foreign papist and a Spaniard to boot.
学术界，史学界在过去，嗯，几十年来，一直认为这，其中大部分是新教宣传，被大规模夸大了，玛丽的处决对于都铎王朝的君主来说并不罕见，甚至她的外交政策也比宣传的要好。所以让我们深入挖掘一下。让我们从血腥玛丽，那个天主教徒，那个疯狂的天主教偏执狂，在土地上横冲直撞，
and that the consequence had been nothing but humiliation. England gets dragged into a war with France that was none of her business. This culminates in the humiliating loss in January 1588 of Calais, which had been the English foothold on the continent since the time of Edward III. And there's this, again, famous story that everyone used to know, that Mary on her deathbed said, when I am dead and opened, you shall find Calais lying in my heart. And, you know, this is Mary as failure as well as bigot. But Tom, this is not now us being revisionist. I mean,
焚烧体面、诚实的新教牧师，所有这些想法开始。这在某种程度上是不真实的，不是吗？我的意思是，当然，人们确实死了，但他们总是死在中世纪和近代早期的君主统治下。我们一直在说她有仁慈的名声，这并非没有道理。她和她的代理人并没有到处搜寻异教徒。那些被指控、审讯，如果他们拒绝忏悔，然后被烧死的人，是被邻居举报的人。
the scholarship, the historiography for the last, well, for decades in our lifetime, has been that this is, much of this is Protestant propaganda, massively inflated, that Mary's executions are nothing unusual for a Tudor monarch, and that even her foreign policy is better than is advertised. So let's dig into this a little bit. So let's start with the idea of Bloody Mary, the Catholic, the mad Catholic bigot, who rampages across the land,
玛丽无疑宁愿不处决他们。她想要他们的忏悔。她不想让他们死。对于玛丽和天主教会的机构来说，每一个殉道者的死亡都是一种失败。现在，我完全可以看出，从我们21世纪的角度来看，这似乎并没有太多的减轻罪责。但问题是，我们在关于苏格兰玛丽女王的系列节目中谈到过这一点，君主的职责是镇压异端和叛乱。
burning, decent, honest, Protestant churchmen, all of this. This is untrue, isn't it, to some extent? I mean, sure, people do die, but they always die in medieval and early modern monarchs. We've been saying throughout that she has a reputation for mercy and that this is not unjustified. She and her agents do not go around sniffing out heretics. The people who are charged and interrogated and if they refuse to repent, then burnt, are people who've been denounced by their neighbours.
而在16世纪，异端和叛乱是等同的。两者之间是不可能区分的。镇压异端是君主的职责。是的，是的，是的，当然。这是一个绝对关键的功能。不到300人。大约有280到290人因异端在玛丽统治下被处决。当你把它放在其他都铎王朝君主所做的事情的背景下时，它开始看起来
And Mary undoubtedly would much rather not have executed them. She wanted their repentance. She didn't want them dead. the death of every martyr for Mary and the apparatus of the Catholic Church is a failure. Now, I can entirely see that from our perspective in the 21st century, this doesn't really seem much of an extenuation. But the thing is, and we talked about this in the series we did on Mary Queen of Scots, a monarch's job is to suppress heresy and rebellion.
没那么糟糕，因为那280、290个死去的人，那是跨越了三年。但如果你看看“恩典朝圣”，那是1537年针对亨利八世的天主教叛乱，亨利处死了250名天主教徒，那基本上是在几周内。是的，是的，是的。你知道，那比玛丽所做的任何事情都要广泛得多。然后在1569年，又发生了一次针对伊丽莎白的叛乱，同样是由天主教徒发起的。她处死了600名天主教徒，我们对此一无所知。而且要明确一点，就像，如果你反叛，我的意思是，你知道这些是惩罚，对吧？
And in the 16th century, heresy and rebellion are equated. It's impossible to distinguish between the two. It's the monarch's job to suppress heresy. Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course. It's an absolutely crucial function. It's under 300. It's about 280 to 290 people who are executed for heresy under Mary. And when you put that in the context of what other Tudor monarchs did, it starts to seem
我的意思是，正如你所说，这绝对是君主的职责。如果人们反叛你，你知道，要么他们赢，要么你赢。如果你只是打他们一下手心说，回家吧，别再做了，你知道，你会在几个月内失去你的王冠。每个人都会说你没用，你让英国失望了。我的意思是，这是职位描述的一部分。确实如此。而且假设那些被烧死的人是玛丽偏执和嗜血的证据，还有一个进一步的复杂性，因为实际上其中几个人在爱德华六世或亨利八世统治下也会被烧死，
less bad because the 280, 290 people who die, that's over a span of three years. But if you look at the Pilgrimage of Grace, which was a camp. Catholic rebellion against Henry the 8th in 1537, Henry put 250 Catholics to death, and that's basically in a few weeks. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, that's on a far, vast, more immediate scale than anything Mary does. And then in 1569, there's a rebellion against Elizabeth, again, by Catholics. And she put 600 Catholics to death, and we don't hear anything about that. And just to be clear, like, if you rebel, I mean, you know that these are the penalties, right?
因为实际上他们的观点是如此异端，以至于即使是新教君主也会认为他们不可接受。所以他们是那些否认三位一体或拒绝基督神性的人。无论你是在新教君主还是天主教君主统治下说这些，那都是死罪。他们是自找的。让我们公平一点。好吧，我的意思是，玛丽做了，她是正确的，这将是16世纪的观点。我的意思是，我完全看出，按照21世纪人文主义者的眼光，这并不是一个充分的减轻罪责。但我认为按照16世纪的标准，它是。我认为玛丽作为血腥的形象是福克斯天才的宣传作品。
I mean, as you said, it's absolutely the monarch's job. If people rebel against you, you know, either they win or you win. And if you just slap them on the wrist and say, go home and don't do it again, you know, you will lose your crown within months. And everybody will say you were useless and you let England down. I mean, this is part of the job description. It is. And there's a further complication in assuming that the people who are burned are a kind of evidence of Mary's bigotry and bloodlust. because actually several of them would have been burned under Edward the Sixth or Henry the 8th
这就是为什么他的书影响如此深远。关于军事失败的记录。即使是那样，我认为也不像看起来那么彻底。英国被拖入这场针对法国的战争，你知道，随心所欲，没有任何利害关系，这根本不是真的。法国是英国的传统敌人。法国总是试图攻击英国。在玛丽统治期间，英国直接受到法国海军规模和能力大幅增加的威胁。听过我们关于苏格兰玛丽女王系列节目的听众可能记得，1548年，法国在军事上干预苏格兰，对抗当时正在进行“粗暴求爱”的英国人。
because actually their views are so heretical that even a Protestant monarch would have regarded them as beyond the pale. So they're people who deny the Trinity or reject the divinity of Christ. That is death whether you are saying it under a Protestant or a Catholic monarch. They had it coming. Let's be fair. Well, I mean, Mary did it and she was right to do it, would be the perspective of the 16th century. I mean, I entirely see that by the lights of a 21st century humanist, this isn't really an adequate extenuation. But I think by the standards of the 16th century, it is. I think the image of Mary as bloody is a genius work of propaganda on the part of Fox.
而且不久之后，五岁的苏格兰玛丽女王被一支法国舰队从克莱德河带到苏格兰。多米尼克，那是著名的时刻，玛丽没有表现出任何晕船的迹象，你对此非常蔑视。她不是亲自掌舵那艘船吗？那不是声称吗？她亲自掌舵那艘船？我认为这不是关于这个事实的关键点。
And that's why his book is so seismically influential. about the record of military failure. Even that, I think, isn't as total as it seemed. The accusation that England is dragged into this war against France, you know, willy-nilly without any stake in it, that's simply not true. France is England's traditional enemy. France is always looking to attack England. And in Mary's reign, England is directly threatened by a massive increase in the size and the capacity of the French Navy. And people who listen to our series on Mary Queen of Scots may remember that in 1548, the French intervene in Scotland militarily against the English, who are doing the rough wooing at the time.
重要的是，法国舰队能够航行到英国一侧并干预苏格兰，然后航行到另一侧，而英国人对此无能为力。原因在于，到玛丽统治时期，英国舰队已经变得非常破旧。自1551年以来，没有建造过任何英国军舰。
And that shortly afterwards, the five-year-old Mary Queen of Scots is brought by a French fatilla from the Clyde down to Scotland. And that is the famous moment, Dominic, where Mary shows no sign of seasickness that you were very contemptuous of. Did she not steer the ship herself? Is that not the claim? that she personally helmed that ship? I think this isn't the salient fact about this.
而纠正这一点的人是西班牙的菲利普。1555年，他对妻子说：“来吧，你必须开始造船了。我们需要让英国海军重新出海。”而导致加来丢失的战争并非全是坏消息。所以引用本杰明·雷丁的话，他写了一篇关于这个的精彩文章，它具有根本的重要性，因为它成为了复兴英国海军的刺激因素。当然，从长远来看，英国的未来不在于在法国维持一个非常、非常昂贵的立足点，即加来。未来在于统治海峡和更远的海域。这是都铎历史的一大讽刺，因为如果
What matters is that the French fleet are able to sail up the side of England and intervene in Scotland and then sail down the other side and the English can't do anything about it. And the reason for that is that by Mary's reign, the English fleet has become very run down. No English warship has been built since 1551.
重要的是法国舰队能够沿着英格兰一侧航行并干预苏格兰，然后从另一侧航行回来，而英格兰对此却无能为力。其原因是到了玛丽女王统治时期，英格兰舰队已经非常破败。自1551年以来，英格兰没有建造过任何一艘军舰。
And the person who rectifies this is Philip of Spain. In 1555 he says to his wife, come on, you've got to get the ship bills hammering. We need to get the English Navy back out to sea. And the war that results in the loss of Calais isn't all bad news. So to quote Benjamin Redding, who's written great essay on this, it was fundamentally important for it acted as the stimulus for reviving the English Navy. And of course, in the long run, England's future does not lie in maintaining a very, very expensive foothold in France, namely Calais. The future lies in ruling the channel and the seas beyond. And this is one of the great ironies of Tudor history, because had
而纠正这一局面的人是西班牙的菲利普。1555年，他对妻子说，来吧，你必须让造船厂开工了。我们需要让英格兰海军重返大海。导致加来失守的那场战争并非全是坏消息。正如本杰明·雷丁（Benjamin Redding）所言，他在一篇关于此事的精彩文章中写道，这具有根本性的重要意义，因为它成为了复兴英格兰海军的催化剂。当然，从长远来看，英格兰的未来并不在于维持在法国一个非常、非常昂贵的立足点，即加来。未来在于统治英吉利海峡以及更广阔的海洋。这是都铎王朝历史上的一大讽刺，因为如果
Mary not married Philip of Spain, then the English fleet in 1588 would not have been in a condition to defeat the Spanish Armada sent by Philip of Spain. So what you're saying is Philip of Spain stands alongside Alfa the Great as the founding father of the Royal Navy. Yes, essentially. I mean, it's one of the delicious ironies of history. So I think you could say that far from tottering, far from being weak, far from being blood-soaked. Actually, by 1558, Mary's regime is looking pretty secure. So Calais has been lost, but England has a fleet that is capable of stopping the French from bringing the attack to English ports. The campaign to restore Catholicism is going well. There's a drop-off in trials for heresy, which suggests
如果玛丽没有嫁给西班牙的菲利普，那么1588年的英国舰队就不可能击败菲利普派出的西班牙无敌舰队。所以你的意思是，西班牙的菲利普与阿尔弗雷德大帝并列为皇家海军的国父？是的，基本上是这样。我的意思是，这是历史中充满讽刺意味的趣事之一。所以我认为你可以说，玛丽的政权远非摇摇欲坠，远非软弱无力，也远非血流成河。事实上，到1558年，玛丽的政权看起来相当稳固。虽然加来失守了，但英国拥有一支能够阻止法国人进攻英国港口的舰队。恢复天主教的运动进展顺利。异端审判的数量有所下降，这表明
that overt Protestantism is starting to be weeded out. Of course, there are still plenty of people in England who have Protestant sympathies, but it's the measure of how successful Mary's Counter-Reformation is, that these, by and large, are content to lie low. And we have a classic example of this. A brilliant young public servant, again, from Lincolnshire, like Fox. It's not Lincolnshire on today's podcast. A lot of Lincolnshire.
公开的新教信仰开始被清除。当然，英国仍有许多人同情新教，但玛丽的反宗教改革之所以成功，就在于这些人大多满足于保持低调。我们有一个经典的例子。一位才华横溢的年轻公职人员，同样来自林肯郡，就像福克斯一样。今天的播客里林肯郡出现得很多。
And this is a guy by the name of William Cecil. So he's only 35 in 1558, but he's a man who's already risen very, very hard. He's proved very proficient at climbing up the slippery pole of power. A committed Protestant had been since his mid-20s. He'd been a student of Roger Asham, the great educationalist and Greek scholar at Cambridge, as Elizabeth had been. He'd been a very committed servant of Edward the 6th regime. He'd been on the council. As a counsellor, he had backed the plot to put Lady Jane Grey on the throne.
这个人名叫威廉·塞西尔。1558年他才35岁，但他已经晋升得非常非常快。他证明了自己在权力的滑杆上攀爬得非常熟练。他从20多岁起就是一名坚定的新教徒。他曾是剑桥大学伟大的教育家和希腊学者罗杰·阿沙姆的学生，伊丽莎白也是。他曾是爱德华六世政权的忠实仆人。他曾在枢密院任职。作为一名顾问，他支持了让简·格雷夫人登上王位的阴谋。
And he is a man who has no doubt that the papacy is. the Antichrist. So people may be wondering, well, how has this man survived Mary coming to power? Like Elizabeth, he's a very subtle, self-disciplined operator. Well, Tom, he sounds like an absolutely splendid man. But the question is, why hadn't he ended up on the chopping block? Like, how has he managed to survive and indeed to flourish under Mary, when surely he should have been one of her targets?
他是一个毫无疑问认为教皇就是敌基督的人。所以人们可能会想，这个男人是怎么在玛丽掌权后幸存下来的？像伊丽莎白一样，他是一个非常微妙、自律的操盘手。嗯，汤姆，他听起来是个非常出色的人。但问题是，他为什么没有被送上断头台？他是如何设法在玛丽统治下幸存甚至蓬勃发展的，毕竟他本应是她的目标之一？
Partly because he's a very subtle, self-disciplined man, a man who knows how he's a how to keep a secret and knows how to bury a secret. Like Elizabeth, he doesn't leave behind paper trails. At the same time, as we've been saying throughout this episode, Mary is not a vengeful woman. She is ready to forgive. She's ready to forget. And so long as men like Cecil are not actively conspiring against her, she is perfectly happy to tolerate them. To coin a phrase, she doesn't want to make windows into men's souls. And this is a wise and by the standards of the age, I think, moderate policy and one that by 1588 seems to be working. And there is a feeling domestically, but also abroad, that England is being won back for the Catholic
部分原因是他是一个非常微妙、自律的人，一个知道如何保守秘密、如何掩埋秘密的人。像伊丽莎白一样，他不留下任何书面痕迹。与此同时，正如我们在本集一直所说的那样，玛丽不是一个复仇心重的女人。她准备宽恕，也准备遗忘。只要像塞西尔这样的人不积极密谋反对她，她就完全乐意容忍他们。借用一句名言，她不想窥探人们的灵魂。我认为，按照那个时代的标准，这是一项明智且温和的政策，而且到1588年，它似乎正在奏效。在国内乃至国外，人们都有一种感觉，英国正在被赢回给天主
church. So one Catholic puts it, England is beginning to recover its pure form. It all seems to be going well. So had history worked out differently, maybe England would have continued along that path towards what Theo describes as England's finest hour. It's reintegration in the world of Catholic continental Europe. But of course it doesn't. Now one reason it doesn't is because all of this is dependent on one woman, right, on the person at the top. And Mary, you know, the tutors have a bit of bad luck, don't they? With Edward VI and now with Mary again. So by the autumn of 1558, she is seriously ill with cancer. She's confined to her bed. She's got kind of constant fevers. She has delirium and stuff. And the issue, again, the perennial Tudor issue, she has no
教会。正如一位天主教徒所言，英国正开始恢复其纯粹的形式。一切似乎都在顺利进行。如果历史的发展有所不同，也许英国会继续沿着西奥所描述的通往“英国最辉煌时刻”的道路前进，即重新融入天主教欧洲大陆的世界。但事实并非如此。原因之一是这一切都取决于一个女人，也就是最高领导人。玛丽，你知道，都铎王朝的运气有点差，不是吗？爱德华六世如此，现在的玛丽也是。到1558年秋天，她患上了严重的癌症。她卧床不起，持续发烧。她出现了谵妄等症状。而问题，又是那个永恒的都铎王朝问题，她没有
child. She has no Catholic heir. And this is not for want of trying. Right. Exactly. So that's what Philip II of Spain. That's what Philip of Spain was for. Yeah. But it just hasn't worked out. And they are, they are living as man and, I mean, they do spend a lot of time apart, but they do live, as it were, as man and wife, right? Well, immediately after the marriage they do. And by April 1555, Mary had been so convinced that she was pregnant that she actually retires to a kind of, you know, a birthing chamber in Hampton Court Palace. And she summons Elizabeth from Woodstock. So this is basically when Elizabeth's in prison and there finishes, obviously because she wants Elizabeth to witness, you know, her supplanting as the air. But the pregnancy had turned out to be
孩子。她没有天主教继承人。这并不是因为没有尝试。没错。正是如此。这就是西班牙菲利普二世的作用。这就是西班牙菲利普的目的。是的。但结果并不如意。他们作为夫妻生活在一起，我的意思是，他们确实分居了很长时间，但他们确实像夫妻一样生活，对吧？嗯，婚后立即是这样。到1555年4月，玛丽确信自己怀孕了，以至于她退居到汉普顿宫的一个产房里。她从伍德斯托克召见了伊丽莎白。这基本上是伊丽莎白被囚禁结束的时候，显然是因为她想让伊丽莎白见证她作为继承人的被取代。但怀孕结果是
a phantom one. And Mary is left humiliated. And I think Philip is left feeling humiliated as well. And so he then leaves England. He does come back for a brief stay in the summer of 1557, but it's only for a few weeks and then he goes off again and they never see each other. And in the wake of that stay, there are further rumours of a pregnancy, but they're not widely believed. And one of Philip's counsellors, a guy called the Count of Faria, it's very blunt about this. And he wrote to Philip, it seems to me the queen is making herself believe that she is with child, although she does not own up to it. And I think that's very astute. And it's kind of Mary's great tragedy. As with Henry, so with Mary. You know, this burning desperation for a child. And it just causes her, you know, she dies knowing that she has failed. Because it means that as she is on her deathbed in October 1558, Elizabeth remains what she'd been since the death of Edward the 6th, their brother, five years before. She is the heir to the throne. And Mary can do. nothing about that. So she hasn't seen Mary for months. She had visited London in earlier in the
幻觉。玛丽感到羞辱。我想菲利普也感到羞辱。于是他离开了英国。他在1557年夏天短暂回来过，但只待了几周，然后又走了，他们再也没有见过面。在那次停留之后，又有关于怀孕的传言，但人们并不相信。菲利普的一位顾问，法里亚伯爵，对此非常直率。他写信给菲利普说，在我看来，女王让自己相信她怀孕了，尽管她并不承认。我认为这非常敏锐。这算是玛丽的巨大悲剧。正如亨利一样，玛丽也是如此。你知道，那种对孩子的极度渴望。这导致她……她死时知道自己失败了。因为这意味着当她在1558年10月临终时，伊丽莎白仍然是她五年前兄弟爱德华六世去世后一直以来的身份。她是王位继承人。而玛丽对此无能为力。所以她已经几个月没见过玛丽了。她在1558年
spring of 1558 and had stayed at Somerset House, hadn't she? And she had, some people think she'd gone there basically to reassure herself that, you know, one of these phantom pregnancies wasn't going to turn out to be a real pregnancy. Yeah. But Elizabeth had used that trip to London to make some important contacts. Yes, she did. So to quote Stephen Olford, who wrote a brilliant book on the person that Elizabeth is meeting at Somerset House, there were no great papers for this meeting. But we know this meeting happened because a servant in the household of the man who is coming to see Elizabeth, kept a record of it, or to be precise, of a boat trip made by his master up and down the Thames, the Somerset House, for the meeting. And the person who was going
春天早些时候访问过伦敦，住在萨默塞特府，不是吗？有些人认为她去那里基本上是为了确认那些幻觉怀孕不会变成真正的怀孕。是的。但伊丽莎白利用那次伦敦之行建立了一些重要的联系。是的，她确实利用了。引用斯蒂芬·奥尔福德的话，他写了一本关于伊丽莎白在萨默塞特府会见的人的精彩著作，这次会面没有留下重要的文件。但我们知道这次会面发生了，因为那个去见伊丽莎白的人的仆人记录了下来，或者更准确地说，记录了他主人乘船在泰晤士河上往返萨默塞特府进行会面的过程。而那个
in the boat, going to meet Elizabeth, to have this secret meeting, was, to quote all for it again, the cleverest young man in Tudor politics. And this man was Sir William Cecil. So that's the person we were just talking about. Yeah. And from this point on, William Cecil effectively is at Elizabeth's right hand. She's setting up a shadow government ready to step in when Mary dies. And on the 10th of November, Elizabeth entertains the Count of Faria, the counsellor of Philip II,
乘船去见伊丽莎白进行秘密会面的人，再次引用奥尔福德的话，是“都铎政治中最聪明的年轻人”。这个人就是威廉·塞西尔爵士。所以这就是我们刚才谈论的那个人。是的。从这一点开始，威廉·塞西尔实际上就成了伊丽莎白的得力助手。她正在建立一个影子政府，准备在玛丽去世时接管政权。11月10日，伊丽莎白在哈特菲尔德附近的布罗基特庄园接待了菲利普二世的顾问、
who's effectively his ambassador, his agent in England, at a house called Brockett Hall near Hatfield, owned by one of Elizabeth's supporters. And there they have a private conversation. And the Count then reports details of this conversation back to Philip. And he says that Elizabeth wants to remain on good terms with Spain, but she's also absolutely insistent that she owes Philip nothing.
实际上是他在英国的大使和代理人法里亚伯爵，该庄园由伊丽莎白的一位支持者拥有。在那里，他们进行了私人谈话。伯爵随后向菲利普报告了这次谈话的细节。他说，伊丽莎白希望与西班牙保持良好关系，但她也绝对坚持认为她不欠菲利普任何东西。
And she emphasises to Faria that it's not Philip who has kept her alive, but rather the love of her people. It was the people who put her in her present position to quote Faria. And he leaves the interview plunged into gloom. I'm very much afraid he wrote that she will not be well disposed in matters of religion, for I see her inclined to govern through men who are believed to be held. And a week later on the morning of 17th November, Mary hears Mass, and then very quietly, she goes to meet her maker.
她向法里亚强调，让她活下来的不是菲利普，而是她人民的爱。引用法里亚的话，是人民把她推到了现在的位置。他离开采访时陷入了阴郁。他写道，我非常担心她在宗教问题上不会表现得很好，因为我看到她倾向于通过那些被认为持有（新教观点）的人来治理国家。一周后的11月17日上午，玛丽听了弥撒，然后非常安静地去见她的造物主了。
She is dead. And the news is brought to Elizabeth at Hatfield. The tradition is that she was sitting under an oak tree when the news arrived, but this is a very late story, and rather sadly seems to be unlikely, but, you know, what the hell? Let's say it happened. A Protestant oak. A Protestant oak. And with her, as the news is brought to her, is William.
她去世了。消息传到了哈特菲尔德的伊丽莎白那里。传统说法是消息传来时她正坐在橡树下，但这只是一个很晚才出现的传说，遗憾的是似乎不太可能，但是，管他呢？我们就当它发生了。一棵新教橡树。一棵新教橡树。当消息传来时，陪在她身边的是威廉。
Cecil. And the queen summons Cecil and her most trusted advisors, the people that she has been preparing with for her reign. And she says to them, my lords, the law of nature moveth me to sorrow for my sister. The burden that has fallen upon me, maketh me amazed. But Cecil, he's not unduly amazed. He's ready. And I think as events will show, Elizabeth has was ready to because she is now against all the odds, Queen of England. Crikey, what a cliffhanger, because in the next episode, which members of the Restis History Club can listen to right now, we will find out what happens when Elizabeth becomes queen, the dawning of the Elizabethan golden age, the issue of her marriage, the revolution that
塞西尔。女王召见了塞西尔和她最信任的顾问，那些她一直为自己的统治做准备的人。她对他们说：“各位大人，自然法则使我为我的姐姐感到悲伤。落在我身上的重担使我感到震惊。”但塞西尔并不感到过度震惊。他准备好了。我认为正如事件所证明的那样，伊丽莎白也准备好了，因为她现在克服了重重困难，成为了英国女王。天哪，真是个悬念，因为在下一集中，历史俱乐部成员现在就可以收听，我们将发现伊丽莎白成为女王后会发生什么，伊丽莎白黄金时代的曙光，她的婚姻问题，以及
she and William Cecil are about to unleash in English religion. and the snake pit, the machinations of Tudor politics as Mary Queen of Scots enters the chat. So if you want to listen to that episode right now, you merely need to go to the rest is history.com to sign up and join the club and you will get a host of unbelievable benefits along with that. But Tom, I can't wait to find out what happens next personally. I'm really looking forward to it because we're going to record it right now. and on that, Balmichel, thank you very much and goodbye everybody. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她和威廉·塞西尔即将引发的英国宗教革命。还有蛇坑，随着苏格兰玛丽女王的加入，都铎政治的阴谋诡计。所以如果你现在想收听那一集，你只需要去therestishistory.com注册并加入俱乐部，你就会得到一大堆令人难以置信的好处。但是汤姆，我个人迫不及待地想知道接下来会发生什么。我真的很期待，因为我们马上就要录制它了。说到这里，巴尔米切尔，非常感谢，再见大家。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。